I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi. Welcome, everyone, to a breakdown of Lotto. Yes. Are you guys ready to get lucky? It's season eight, episode three. It was written by Charlie Grandy, directed by John Krasinski, and was an episode that received a solid B rating from reviewer Miles McNutt. Way to go. Would you like a summary? You know I would. When the warehouse crew
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是好闺蜜。现在，我们专门为你带来了《办公室》的终极重温播客。每周，我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。嗨。欢迎大家收看关于《乐透》的解析。对的。你们准备好走运了吗？这是第八季第三集。由查理·格兰迪编剧，约翰·卡拉辛斯基导演，这集获得了评论员迈尔斯·麦克纳特给出的稳固的B级评价。干得好。你想听剧情梗概吗？你知道我当然想。当仓库员工
win the lottery and quit their jobs, the upstairs employees are left to pick up the slack until a new crew can be hired. Aaron, Jim, Dwight, and Kevin can't seem to figure out how to load boxes of paper into a delivery truck. It takes them all day. And then they don't even finish. All day. And not just all day, but they become like Wiley E. Coyote trying to build some kind of device to load them. It's just, it's bonkers. In the meantime, a very depressed Daryl issues an ultimatum to Andy. He says, fire me or make me manager. Yeah. And then the rest of the gang fantasize about what they would do if they had win the lottery, which causes a little friction between Pam and Jim. They have dueling fantasies.
赢得彩票并辞职后，楼上的员工们只得收拾烂摊子，直到新员工被招募进来。艾伦、吉姆、德怀特和凯文似乎怎么也搞不懂该怎么把一箱箱纸搬进送货卡车。他们折腾了一整天。最后甚至都没搬完。一整天。不仅是一整天，而且他们变得就像歪心狼试图制造某种装置来装载货物一样。简直太疯狂了。与此同时，一个非常沮丧的达里尔给安迪下了最后通牒。他说，要么解雇我，要么让我当经理。是的。然后剩下的伙伴们开始幻想如果他们中彩票会做什么，这在帕姆和吉姆之间引发了一些摩擦。他们的幻想针锋相对。
Yeah, they don't get along in their fantasy lives. They don't. Which normally you would think that your marriage is even better and stronger in your fantasy life, but not so. Or in your fantasy life, is it more clear because you have options? Oh, oh, that's a very like therapisty thing to say, Angela. I like that. I love that thought. Journal on that, everybody. Well, listen, we don't have any fast facts today because instead we have an amazing interview with Mark Brooks, who plays Nate, who is featured in this episode, but who also appears in 19 episodes of the office spanning three seasons. We can't be more excited for you to hear this interview. He's an absolute delight of a person. Yes,
是的，他们在各自的幻想生活中合不来。确实合不来。通常你可能会认为在幻想生活中你的婚姻会更好、更牢固，但事实并非如此。或者在你的幻想生活中，因为你有选择，所以事情会更清晰？哦，哦，安吉拉，这听起来太像心理治疗师会说的话了。我喜欢这样。我太喜欢这个想法了。大家把这个写进日记里吧。好了，听着，我们今天没有什么快速事实，因为取而代之的是，我们对马克·布鲁克斯进行了一次精彩的采访。他饰演奈特，不仅在本集中出场，还在跨越三季的19集《办公室》中亮相。我们无比期待你们听到这采访。他绝对是一个令人愉悦的人。是的，
we have wanted to talk to him for a while. And this is not the last time we're talking to him because we have more, more to ask Mark about as the seasons progress. And I know that we always say that everybody is so nice and amazing. But I think you're going to hear in this interview that Mark is like at the top. Yeah, he's the best. He's 100% real deal. And here you go. Here's our conversation with Mark. Mark, hello. Welcome to Office Ladies. Thank you guys for having me. I really appreciate it. Well, we are so excited to talk to you. We are really enjoying Nate and Nate has some real fun stuff coming up. And we just know the fans can't wait to hear from you. Well, that's exciting. I've been
我们一直想和他聊聊。这也不是我们最后一次和他聊，随着剧集的推进，我们还有更多、更多关于马克的问题想问。我知道我们总是说每个人都超级好、超棒。但我相信你在这期采访中会听到，马克简直是顶流。是的，他是最棒的。百分之百的真性情。给，这就是我们和马克的对话。马克，你好。欢迎来到《办公室女郎》。谢谢你们邀请我。我真的很感激。好吧，我们很高兴能和你谈谈。我们真的很喜欢奈特，奈特接下来会有一些非常有趣的事情。我们知道粉丝们已经迫不及待地想听到你的声音了。太令人兴奋了。我
waiting a long time to get my chance to talk on Office Ladies. So Mark, when your character was introduced, we told a little bit of your origin story, but I just want you to tell it again in your own words from the beginning. This is our favorite question to ask our guests. How did you get your job on the office? I quite honestly backed into it. I was unemployed living in Wisconsin in Milwaukee. And I had this idea to make my friends laugh, which was go on morning news shows as a character and a character that would be in nept and clumsy. But the main thing was that the anchors and the the news station had no idea I was in character. Now, I had never taken acting classes or anything like that. I just thought
等了好久才得到机会在《办公室女郎》里说话。马克，当你的角色刚登场时，我们讲了一点你的起源故事，但我希望你能用你自己的话从头再讲一遍。这是我们最喜欢问嘉宾的问题。你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？说实话，我误打误撞进来的。当时我在威斯康星州密尔沃基无业度日。我有个能让朋友们发笑的点子，那就是以一个笨拙且冒失的角色身份上早间新闻节目。但重点是，主播和新闻台根本不知道我在演戏。当时我从没上过表演课或做过类似的事情。我只是觉得
it would be funny. And so I would go on these morning shows as this yo-yo master, which case case, the yo-yo master who was not a master of the yo-yo. No, because I can't yo-yo. I'm not even a big fan of yo-yoing. And so I would get on and start rambling about my chaotic personal life. And finally, they would ask me to do a demonstration, and that would go horribly wrong. The idea was to do 10 or 11 or 12 of these. And if you watch them all in a row, you would get this kind of strange story arc about this guy's life, all told through two minute, one minute segments on morning shows. Now, I have to stop you because you're saying you never took any acting classes. Did you
那样会很搞笑。于是我就以这个“溜溜球大师”的身份上早间新闻节目，巧合的是，这个溜溜球大师其实并不擅长溜溜球。对，因为我不会玩溜溜球。我也不是溜溜球的超级粉丝。然后我就会上台，开始胡言乱语地讲我混乱的个人生活。最后，他们会要求我做个示范，事情就会变得一团糟。我的计划是做10个、11个或12个这样的节目。如果你把它们连起来看，你就会得到一个关于这个家伙生活的奇异故事线，所有这些都是通过早间节目上一分钟、两分钟的片段讲述出来的。等等，我得打断你一下，因为你说你从来没上过任何表演课。你
take like improv or sketch comedy? No? No, I never did any of that. What about like a writing class? Because there is a real story arc there. Yeah, it's no, you know, all that was just myself wanting to do this. I'm so fascinated by this. I always have been, I've made you tell me this story so many times because every time it just blows my mind. Okay, so I'll let you go on. Okay, so I did these appearances. And like I said, the idea was to do 10, 11, 12 and to get a story arc. And what I didn't expect was for people to start posting them on YouTube.
上过即兴表演或素描喜剧课吗？没有？没有，我从来没做过那些。那写作课呢？因为那里确实有一个完整的故事线。对，没有，你知道，所有这些都只是我自己想这么做。我对这个太着迷了。我一直都这样，我让你给我讲了这么多次这个故事，因为每次都让我大开眼界。好吧，那我让你继续说。好吧，我就去上了这些节目。就像我说的，计划是做10个、11个、12个来形成一条故事线。而我没想到的是人们开始把它们发到YouTube上。
And this was back in 2010. And so there were still videos that could really catch fire and become viral. And the K-Stress morning show appearances became viral. And I at first I was really annoyed because I was like, well, they've ruined my opportunity here to tell like this story arc I want to tell. Because I had no idea of, you know, coming to LA coming to Hollywood. And oddly enough, a friend of mine got a text message from one of the writers on the show. And she figured out who I was through computer sleuthing and what have you. And she asked if I, you know, would I want to talk to Paul Lieberstein and who was running the show. And I was like, yeah, of course I would. A few minutes later, Paul calls
那是2010年。所以那时候还有真正能火爆并病毒式传播的视频。我的K-Stress早间新闻节目片段火了。起初我真的很恼火，因为我想，好吧，他们毁了我在这里讲述我想讲的那条故事线的机会。因为我根本没想过要来洛杉矶，来好莱坞。说来也巧，我的一个朋友收到了剧组某个编剧的短信。她通过电脑人肉搜索等等弄清了我是谁。她问我，你知道的，我愿不愿意和保罗·利伯斯坦聊聊，当时他是剧集运作人。我说，我当然愿意。几分钟后，保罗打电话
me. Oh my gosh. And all of a sudden I'm talking to Toby from the office. And a month later, they flew me out. I met with the writers. And a month after that, I was on the show. I mean, wow, that's crazy. The real crazy thing here. Yeah. The writer that reached out was my now wife, Amelie Gillette, who had just started writing on the show a couple weeks before all this blew up. So you got an arc on the office and a wife out of this the yo-yo idea that was just meant to entertain your friends. It's an incredible story. You know, it's you don't hear too many stories like this anymore. You know, it's it's usually oh, I was working for 12, 15 years. Yeah. You know, I'd started in commercials and what
给我。哦天哪。突然之间我在和《办公室》的托比通话。一个月后，他们用飞机把我接了过去。我和编剧们见了面。又过了一个月，我就参演了。我的天，哇，太疯狂了。真正疯狂的事情是。对。联系我的那个编剧就是我现在的老妻阿米莉·吉莱特，就在这一切爆发前几周，她刚开始在剧组担任编剧。所以你通过这个本来只是为了娱乐朋友的溜溜球点子，在《办公室》里赢得了故事线，还收获了一个老婆。这是一个不可思议的故事。你知道，现在已经很少听到这样的故事了。通常都是，哦，我干了12年、15年。对。你知道，我从拍广告开始，诸如此类。
have you. And I feel kind of guilty because it was kind of overnight almost. But I I I'm so grateful that it all happened. I got so much out of just making a jackass of myself on morning news. So you had seen the office before you got cast. Obviously. Oh yeah. What was it like to walk on to the set? You know, the first person I met from the cast was rain and I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. I can't imagine what that was like. Now you guys can say that because he is the sweetest, nicest, most genuine person. He's a good, good soul. Exactly. And so, you know, it could have gone to one of two ways. And after now, I've been acting for, you know, quite a few years now. And I've as a guest star have gone on many shows.
我甚至有点内疚，因为它几乎是一夜之间发生的。但我非常感激这一切都发生了。我在早间新闻里出洋相，结果收获颇丰。所以在你被选角之前你看过《办公室》。当然。走进片场是什么感觉？你知道，我见到的演员中的第一个人是雷恩，对不起。我很抱歉。我无法想象那是什么感觉。现在你们可以这么说，因为他是最甜美、最好、最真诚的人。他是一个好得不能再好的灵魂。没错。所以，你知道，事情可能会走向两个方向。现在我已经演了好几年戏了，而且作为一个客串演员，我上过很多节目。
The cast is either welcoming or they can be a little cold and a little distance because here comes a new face and that's time away from you as an actor and your character. Or you can just, you know, a high tide lifts all boats type scenario where they're happy that there's fresh people coming in. And you guys were so nice and welcoming to me. I really got spoiled coming into the show because of that, because you guys were so nice and welcoming. And what a first show to cut your teeth on as an actor. I mean, everyone was so generous and encouraging from the top down. I looked back on it and I was so lucky, so very, very fortunate.
演员们要么很热情，要么可能有点冷淡、有点疏离，因为来了一张新面孔，这就分走了属于你作为一个演员和你的角色时间。或者你可以，你知道，这是一种众人划桨开大船的场景，他们很高兴有新鲜血液加入。而你们对我真的太好、太热情了。因为这个，我刚进剧组就被惯坏了，因为你们太友好了。作为演员，这真是一个绝佳的处女秀。从上到下，每个人都那么慷慨和鼓励。回想起来，我真是太幸运了，非常、非常幸运。
Well, you know, this episode we're breaking down is the Lotto, but we all felt like we won the lottery ticket, you know, the minute we were cast. Yeah. So I love hearing that because that's how we felt on set. We were just really happy to be there and counted ourselves lucky every day. But Mark, we wanted to ask you if you have any favorite memories or behind the scene moment or anything you would want to share from your time on the show. Gosh, there are so many, you know, anytime I could get one of you guys to break. I was a feather in my cap, especially as a, you know, a person just starting out and acting.
好吧，你知道，我们这集解析的是《乐透》，但我们所有人从被选中的那一刻起，都觉得自己中了彩票，你知道的。是的。所以我很乐意听到这个，因为我们在片场也是这种感觉。我们只是很高兴能身处那里，每天都觉得自己很幸运。不过，马克，我们想问问你，你有没有什么最喜欢的记忆、幕后时刻，或者任何你想分享的在剧组时光？天哪，有太多了，你知道，任何时候只要我能让你们中有人笑场。我都觉得很骄傲，尤其是作为一个刚开始演戏的人。
I felt like, you know, there was a scene I remember with Jenna where I'm, she's grilling me. And I think it was in season nine, vandalism. We're down in the warehouse. Yeah. It's one of my strongest memories of breaking. And we just had so much fun. And it's such a fun memory for me that that moment. You know, the first day on the show or my first time ever in front of a set in front of a crew filming, I had to knock down a beehive that was in front of the office. And that was the first time I had ever acted in my life professionally or in front of a crew. And all of a sudden you're, you're in front of 35 people, 40 people, all looking at you.
我觉得，你知道，我记得和珍娜有一场戏，我在……她盘问我。我想那是在第九季的《破坏公物》。我们在仓库下面。是的。这是我最深刻的笑场记忆之一。我们玩得太开心了。对我来说，那个时刻是一段非常有趣的记忆。你知道，在剧组的第一天，或者说我第一次面对片场、面对摄影机拍摄时，我必须打掉办公室前面的一个蜂巢。那是我一生中第一次专业演戏，也是第一次在摄制组面前演戏。突然之间，你站在35个人、40个人面前，所有人都看着你。
And I just remember thinking to myself, well, either you can do this or you can't, but there's no real going back. So you might as well give it your all. And I had, it's one of those moments where you're both terrified, but having so much fun. And it just felt right. And I had never had a moment like that in my, in my life. Wow. Well, I just remember all of us being very enamored with you in scenes. You were this character and you had this way about you that was so unique and so deeply funny. It was so deeply funny to me, Mark, the way you did Nate.
我只记得当时心里在想，好吧，要么你能做到，要么你做不到，但已经没有回头路了。所以你最好全力以赴。我有过这种时刻，你既感到恐惧，又觉得无比开心。感觉棒极了。我生命中从未有过这样的时刻。哇。好吧，我只记得我们所有人都非常迷恋你在剧中的表现。你是这个角色，你有一种非常独特且极其搞笑的风格。马克，你演奈特的方，对我来说实在太搞笑了。
It was so earnest. Yes. So earnest. And you had. And real. And yes, you, you would do this thing that Steve did. That was really hard for me. You have a look that comes across your face. I can't really explain it, but Steve has it as well. And if I catch your eye when you kind of do this, it's this expression of like, huh, I'm a goner. I am a goner.
太认真了。是的。太认真了。而且你有。真实。而且，是的，你会做出史蒂夫做过的那种动作。这对我来说真的很难。你的脸上会出现一种表情。我真的很难解释，但史蒂夫也有这种表情。如果我捕捉到你的眼神，当你做出这种表情时，那是一种“哈，我完蛋了。我死定了”的表情。
And so there were a few actors on set that I couldn't make eye contact with really directly. And you and Steve are like top two. Well, good Lord, that's high praise. Yeah, I, you know, it may just be my dumb face, but I'll take the compliment. Thank you. It just, I believed everything you were saying. That's what it is. In rewatching the show, another scene that I remember that was just insane that I got to be in with you as well was the, the toilet paper machine scenes where you had to unply and reply the toilet paper. Do you remember that thing?
所以片场有几个演员，我真的无法跟他们直接对视。你和史蒂夫排在前两名。好吧，老天爷，这评价太高了。是的，你知道，可能只是我那愚蠢的脸，但我接受这个赞美。谢谢。这只是因为我相信你说的每一句话。这就是原因。在重温这部剧时，我记得的另一场同样疯狂的戏，也是我有幸和你一起演的，就是卫生纸机器的那场戏，你得把卫生纸拆开再卷回去。你还记得那个东西吗？
Oh, absolutely. That was, that's one of the most reference scenes I get when people come up to me. But yeah, that, I just remember being shown the contraption and how to work it. And I just thought, wow, this is, this is a lot of work for a quick joke. And that's why I loved the office is that a lot of times there would, there would be a lot of, of groundwork ahead of the joke, especially for these physical jokes, like the replying and, and unplying of the toilet paper machine. Yeah, that honestly, it's, it's the most referenced scene that I get. I believe it. We have people like wrote in that asked us how it was built. Like they're
哦，当然。每当有人走过来找我时，那都是被提到最多的场景之一。但是，是的，我只记得当时有人向我展示那个装置以及如何操作它。我当时就想，哇，为了一个快梗，这活儿干得也太费劲了吧。这也是我喜欢《办公室》的原因，很多时候，在包袱响之前会有很多铺垫，尤其是对于这些肢体笑话，比如把卫生纸机拆开再卷回去。是的，老实说，那是我被问到最多的场景。我相信。我们有粉丝写信问它是怎么制造的。就像他们
just fascinated by all of it and Phil Shea in the props department. Yeah. You know, it's one of those things that I look back on. And I, again, I think, gosh, what a show to just come in on that everyone's loving what they're doing. Every department was in love with the show. And you don't realize how rare that is until you start working on other stuff. And they didn't look at it as just a nine to five. They really loved everyone involved and loved what they were doing. And it's, it shows on the screen, I think, today. When people ask you about your time on the office, what are some of the most frequently asked questions? Like, what do people want to know?
对这一切都着迷一样，还有道具部门的菲尔·谢伊。是的，你知道，回首往事，我觉得，天哪，能参演这样一部大家都热爱自己所做事情的剧，真是一个奇迹。每个部门都深爱着这部剧。直到你开始参与其他工作，你才意识到这种氛围有多么罕见。他们不把它只当作朝九晚五的工作。他们真的爱身边的每一个人，也热爱他们所做的事。我想，直到今天，屏幕上依然能呈现出这一点。当人们问起你在《办公室》的时光时，最常问的问题是什么？人们想知道什么？
People would often ask, did you guys break all the time? Was it always really fun to be on set? And I also get a lot of, you know, are the characters like that in real life? Are the actors like their characters? Which is still fascinating today that we get these types of questions because, you know, you hear stories of people writing into I love Lucy being mad at Ricky and first reading his wife that way. And you're like, gosh, that was such a quaint naive time. But it still happens. People are like, you know, is Angela really uptight? And it's like, no, not really at all. You know, and, you know, is Mindy really like that? No, Mindy's not really like that.
人们经常会问，你们当时总笑场吗？在片场是不是一直都特别好玩？我还会听到很多，你知道，这些角色在现实生活中也是这样吗？演员们和他们的角色像吗？直到今天，听到这类问题依然让我觉得很着迷，因为，你知道，你会听到这样的故事：当年人们写信给《我爱露西》剧组，对里奇和他的妻子在现实中那样感到生气。你会觉得，天哪，那真是一个古朴天真的时代。但这种情况依然存在。人们会问，你知道，安吉拉真的很刻薄吗？然后就会发现，不，其实一点也不。你知道，而且，你知道，明迪真的那样吗？不，明迪才不是那样。
Maybe a little. Maybe a little. Is Brian dumb? It's like, no, Brian's a very smart guy. That's usually what I get asked. Do you still get recognized as Nate? I do, which is crazy to me because I'm, you know, 10 years heavier and doughier than I was back then. The really surprising thing is the age. And I'm sure you guys are getting this as well, probably far more than I am. Younger people that come up to me, teenagers, and people in their early 20s who love the show. We were in Italy just last week and
也许有一点。也许有一点。布赖恩很蠢吗？通常得到的回答是，不，布赖恩是个非常聪明的人。这就是我通常被问到的问题。你现在走在街上还会被认出来是奈特吗？会的，这对我来说太疯狂了，因为我比当年胖了10磅，脸也更圆了。真正令人惊讶的是粉丝的年龄。我确信你们俩也遇到了，可能比我遇到得还要多。喜欢这部剧的年轻人、青少年以及刚20岁出头的人。我们上周刚去过意大利，
I went into a wine shop there and it was a young guy behind the counter. And he knew me as Nate from the office and that blew my mind because, you know, I've I've done stuff since then, but the office still is so relevant to this day. What luck and what a blessing that we got to be on that show. It's just amazing. Well, you have some fun episodes coming up. So we are going to keep pestering you because there's one or two, I don't want to give it away, but Dwight Angela wedding moments that I want to ask you about. I guess I did just give it away if you're watching it for the first time. Yeah, some of those episodes.
我去了那里的一家葡萄酒商店，柜台后是一个年轻人。他认出我是《办公室》里的奈特，这让我大吃一惊，因为，你知道，在那之后我也拍过其他作品，但《办公室》直到今天依然如此具有现实意义。我们能参演那部剧，是何等的幸运和福气。简直太棒了。好吧，你接下来还有一些有趣的剧集要播出。所以我们要继续纠缠你，因为有一两个——我不想剧透——但关于德怀特和安吉拉婚礼的时刻，我想问问你。我想如果观众是第一次看的话，我刚才确实剧透了。是的，其中一些剧集。
Nate, I thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies and sharing your story with us. You know, in my book that I wrote, which is The Actor's Life, a survival guide, it's like advice for aspiring actors. You were kind enough to let me share your story in that book as well. Because I think like there's a lot of people who are anywhere in the world and they have these artistic things inside of them that they want to express. And I think you're such a great example of just doing it, just expressing it for no even known goal. Just because the world needs laughter and artists and creativity, and then it completely transformed your life. But I just love your story so much. I think it's so inspiring.
奈特，非常感谢你来到《办公室女郎》和我们分享你的故事。你知道，在我写的那本书《演员的生活：生存指南》里，里面有给有志演员的建议。你非常慷慨，允许我在那本书里分享你的故事。因为我觉得，世界上有很多人，他们内心深处有各种想要表达的艺术想法。而你就是一个绝佳的例子，你只是去做了，仅仅是为了表达它，甚至没有任何已知的目标。只是因为这个世界需要欢笑、艺术家和创造力，然后它彻底改变了你的生活。我太喜欢你的故事了。我觉得太鼓舞人心了。
Oh, thank you. I really appreciate that. I truly, truly believe that if you do good work, if you have a point of view, and you're truly interested and passionate about your take on comedy or drama or anything or enacting, I wholeheartedly believe that the cream rides us to the top. And that people will take notice. Especially nowadays, there's so many different ways to show your talent out there and show your creativity. Don't get disheartened by all the flocksom and jutsom that is out there. Just keep doing what you find to be interesting and unique and hopefully others will find that to be the case. Yeah, I so agree. I so agree. It's not just the idea, but it's a call to action if you
哦，谢谢。我真的很感激。我真心实意地相信，如果你做好了工作，如果你有自己的观点，并且对你对喜剧或戏剧或任何事情或表演的看法真正感兴趣并充满热情，我全心全意地相信金子总会发光。人们会注意到这一点。尤其是现在，有很多不同的方式来展现你的才华和创造力。不要被外面那些乱七八糟的杂音所打击。只管去做你觉得有趣且独特的事情，希望别人也会这么认为。是的，我太赞同了。我太赞同了。这不仅是一个想法，更是一个行动号召，如果你
have it to try it, you know, and put it out there. Absolutely. Mark, is there anything that you're working on now that we could share with our listeners where they could see you doing more stuff? Yeah, I'm currently on a show called What We Do In The Shadows. We're going into our fifth, well, the fifth season is about to drop on FX, and we're going to be filming the sixth season in the fall. So that's what I've been working on. Well, Mark, we just absolutely adore you. We definitely want you back on Office Ladies.
有了这个想法就去尝试，你知道的，把它展现出来。绝对的。马克，你现在有什么正在进行的工作可以和我们的听众分享，让他们能看到你更多的作品吗？是的，我目前正在参演一部名为《吸血鬼生活》的剧。我们的第五季，好吧，第五季马上要在FX上线了，我们秋天还要拍第六季。这就是我最近在忙的工作。好吧，马克，我们真的太喜欢你了。我们绝对想让你再次做客《办公室女郎》。
And if there's ever anything we can give a shout out to our uplift, we're here for you. Well, I really appreciate you guys having me on. This has been fun to reminisce, but also just has been so great to get to see you too. Yeah. Will you tell Amelie we said hello as well? Yeah, absolutely. She was excited. I was doing this, so. Yay! Yay!
如果以后有什么需要我们宣传或打call的，我们随时待命。好吧，我真的很感激你们邀请我。这次回忆往事非常有趣，能见到你们俩也太棒了。是的。替我们向阿米莉问好，好吗？好的，没问题。她听说我要来做这个节目，还挺兴奋的呢。耶！耶！
We are back. Let's jump right in. It looks like everybody has gone to get coffee, not at Dwight's caffeine corner. Where did they go? Where are they coming back from? I have questions. Why isn't Dwight annoyed that people shop somewhere other than the caffeine corner? Huh? Angela, I love how they're walking up with these drinks as if there is some business around the corner where they purchase these items. When we know that the only thing around that hedge is a junkyard. Yeah, and a train track.
我们回来了。让我们直接切入正题。看起来大家都去买咖啡了，不是在德怀特的咖啡角。他们去哪儿了？他们是从哪儿回来的？我有很多疑问。为什么德怀特不为人们去咖啡角以外的地方买东西而感到恼火？哈？安吉拉，我喜欢他们拿着这些饮料走过来的样子，就好像转角处有什么商业街让他们买到这些东西一样。而我们都知道，那个树篱周围唯一的东西就是一个废品回收站。是的，还有一条铁轨。
Yes, but you're right. They have come back with these, I guess, blended drinks and they're going to come upon Oscar who has noticed that there is a dog inside of a car and he is outraged. He is ready to just go off. I mean, what classic snowboarder move? Leave your dog in the car with the windows up. Yeah, probably didn't leave his weed in the car. Nope. Well, Oscar ends up smashing the window, but then not letting the dog out and then taping up the window. Oh, he's also smashed the tail light of the car for good measure. Let's just
是的，但你说得对。他们带着这些，我猜是混合饮料回来了，然后他们遇到了奥斯卡，奥斯卡发现车里有一只狗，他出离愤怒了。他准备大发雷霆。我的天，多么典型的滑雪客作风？把狗留在车里，窗户还关着。对，可能没把大麻留在车里。没有。好吧，奥斯卡最后砸碎了车窗，但没有把狗放出来，然后用胶带把车窗封上了。哦，他还顺便砸碎了车的尾灯。让我们
pump the brakes for one second. Dwight pours his milkshake through the sunroof. This means the sunroof is open. This means, you know, not great that the dog's in the car, but there's an open sunroof. The dog is not, in fact, enclosed with no air. Oscar did not need to bash out a window. There's an open sunroof. We got a fan mail flurry about that, Angela. Well, good. Also, the sunroof is clearly letting in more air than Oscar's cardboard window with holes in it.
踩一下刹车，停一秒钟。德怀特把他的奶昔从天窗倒了进去。这意味着天窗是开着的。这意味着，你知道的，狗在车里固然不太好，但天窗是开着的。事实上，狗并不是被关在没有空气的环境里。奥斯卡根本不需要砸碎车窗。天窗是开着的。我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝来信讨论这个，安吉拉。好吧，很好。而且，天窗明显比奥斯卡那个带洞的纸板窗户进风更多。
Yeah. You know, Jenna, I had an alternate pitch for the title of this episode. Oh, what is it? So much sass. So much sass? Yeah. It starts with Oscar. It's going to continue, and I'm going to point out the sass the whole way through.
是的。你知道，珍娜，我对这一集的标题有一个备选提案。哦，是什么？太傲慢了。太傲慢了？是的。从奥斯卡开始。这还会继续，而且我要全程指出这种傲慢。
I will look forward to that. So in addition to the fan mail flurry about the sunroof being open, we got a lot of fan questions about this cold open, and I'm happy to say that Steve Burgess gave us all the answers. Are you ready? Yes. Go Steve. Our first question comes from Maddie in College Station, Texas, who wanted to know how hot
我会拭目以待的。所以，除了关于天窗开着的狂热粉丝来信外，我们还收到了很多关于这个开场白粉丝提问，我很高兴地宣布，史蒂夫·伯吉斯给我们解答了所有问题。准备好了吗？是的。说吧，史蒂夫。我们的第一个问题来自德克萨斯州大学城的马迪，她想知道
was it on the day that the dog was in the car, and how was the stunt done to ensure that the dog did not get overheated in real life? Steve told me that the weather that day was a sunny 88 degrees. However, we shot first thing in the morning, so it was a bit cooler. Oh, yeah. It probably would have been like in the 60s. Yes. That's how the days go here in LA. They start out cool jacket weather, then it shorts and t-shirt, and then by evening you're putting that jacket back on again.
狗在车里的那天天气有多热，剧组是怎么做特技以确保狗在现实中不会中暑的？史蒂夫告诉我，那天是个艳阳天，气温高达88华氏度。不过，我们一大早就开拍了，所以天气凉爽一些。哦，是的。大概也就60多度的样子吧。是的。洛杉矶的天气就是这样。一早开始是适合穿夹克的凉爽天气，然后变成短袖T恤，到了晚上你又得把夹克穿回来了。
Steve said that the dog was only in the car for the shots that we see him, that he actually did not spend very much time in the car at all. Same thing goes for Brian, who gets in his own car. Yeah, as Kevin. He wasn't sure if we had pointed this out on a previous podcast, but Kevin's car was Veda's car in real life. Oh, really? Our script supervisor.
史蒂夫说，狗只在我们需要拍它镜头的那些时间里待在车里，实际上它在车里待的时间非常短。布赖恩也是如此，他上了他自己的车。对，作为凯文。他不确定我们是否在之前的播客中提过，凯文的车实际上是维达的车。哦，真的吗？我们的剧本监督。
Yes. Steve also said that we used, of course, Bob Dunn's animal trainers for this stunt. The trainers were Rick and Benita, and the dog's real name was Tango. Tango. Mm-hmm. Now, next fan question, Cameron C. from California wanted to know, how messy did the car get from Dwight pouring his slushie in, and also wanted to know whose car was it? Well, this car was not a crew member's car.
是的。史蒂夫还说，我们这次特技当然使用了鲍勃·邓恩的动物驯兽师。驯兽师是里克和贝尼塔，那只狗的真名叫探戈。探戈。嗯哼。接下来是粉丝提问，来自加利福尼亚州的卡梅伦·C想知道，德怀特倒冰沙把车弄得有多脏，还想知道这辆车是谁的？好吧，这辆车不是剧组人员的车。
This was a rented car. Thank goodness. Right? I know. Could you imagine? No. This was a rented car from Cinema Vehicles. Steve said the car did get pretty messy.
这是一辆租来的车。谢天谢路。对吧？我懂。你能想象吗？不。这是一辆从电影汽车公司租来的车。史蒂夫说车确实弄得挺脏的。
They had to clean it up. They also had a glass guy who was standing by to put new glass windows in, but they were the fake glass windows. He said, we were able to do the glass breaking in only two takes, and if you look really closely, you will see that when Oscar breaks the window, there is no dog in the car. Like, he's not in the car anywhere. I think they were hoping you'd think maybe he jumped in the front seat or maybe into the back.
他们不得不把它清理干净。他们还安排了一个玻璃工人在旁边待命，准备装上新的玻璃窗，但那是假玻璃窗。他说，我们只拍了两条就完成了砸玻璃的镜头，如果你仔细看，你会发现当奥斯卡砸碎车窗时，车里根本没有狗。就是，他根本不在车里的任何地方。我想他们是希望你以为他可能跳到了前座或者后座。
Scooched over to the other side. Yeah. Yeah. But at one minute, two seconds, it's very clear that there is no dog in there. And then, you know, even though it was tempered glass that didn't have any sharp edges, they cleaned all that out and then put the dog back into the car for the rest of the scene. And that's how we did it. There you go.
溜到另一边去了。对。对。但在1分02秒时，很明显里面没有狗。然后，你知道的，尽管那是没有锋利边缘的钢化玻璃，他们把那些碎渣都清理干净了，然后又把狗放回车里拍接下来的戏。事情就是这样完成的。就是这样。
Ultimately, you know, no one wants to adopt the dog, so they do leave the dog in the car with an open sunroof and the cardboard, whole, punchy things. And I just want to know whose car was that and who walked back to that car. Wouldn't you come in the building and complain or file a police report? Yeah. I mean, it's not going to be that difficult to figure out who vandalized this car. No. The first thing I would do is be like, well, first of all, I would go into the, you know,
说到底，你知道，没有人愿意领养这只狗，所以他们就把狗留在了车里，车顶天窗开着，还弄了带洞的纸板糊着。我只想知道那辆车到底是谁的，是谁走回那辆车跟前的？难道你不会走进大楼抱怨或者报警吗？对。我的意思是，弄清楚是谁破坏了这辆车并不难。不。我要做的第一件事就是，首先，我要走进
the building and say, Hank, whose car is that? There's a dog in it. That's what I would do. Yeah. First of all. No. Not our office crew. I would smash the window open with a tire iron, Angela.
大楼说：“汉克，那是谁的车？里面有只狗。”这就是我要做的。对。首先。不。不是我们办公室的人。我会用轮胎撬棒把窗户砸开，安吉拉。
No, no, I'd find who it was and then shame them. That would, that would have worked well for your episode so much sass. I know. So much shame could be another episode. So much shame. Back in the bullpen, we're going to find out that the warehouse has won the lottery. I mean, they won $950,000. It's about $100,000 a person and they all quit.
不，不，我会找出那是谁然后羞辱他们。这倒挺适合你那一集《太傲慢了》的。我懂。所以《太羞辱了》可以作为另一集。太羞辱了。回到办公区，我们会发现仓库赢了乐透。我是说，他们赢了95万美元。每个人大概能分到10万美元，然后他们都辞职了。
Well, $100,000 before taxes. Well, that's true. That's true. But they quit. They're like, we're out of here. I mean, they come up and celebrate. There's dancing. Someone moons everybody.
嗯，税前10万美元。嗯，也是。确实如此。但他们辞职了。他们就像是，我们不干了。我是说，他们跑上来庆祝。有人在跳舞。还有人向大家露屁股。
Yeah. We got a fan question from Eli and Avery W from Lake County, BC. At the very beginning when the warehouse people win the lottery, they pick up Meredith. Was that scripted? You know what? It was scripted. Here is what it said in the shooting draft. D-roll.
是的。我们收到了来自BC省莱克县的伊莉安和埃弗里·W的粉丝提问。在刚开始仓库员工中彩票的时候，他们抱起了梅雷迪思。那是剧本里写好的吗？你知道吗？剧本里确实有。拍摄剧本里是这样写的。达里尔。
The warehouse guys burst into the office cheering and hugging. One of them moons Andy. Meredith jumps on Glen. Oh. Yeah. He didn't pick her up. Meredith just wanted to join in the party. Well, Daryl's ex, Justine, is going to call him and congratulate him on his lotto win.
仓库的小伙子们欢呼雀跃、又蹦又抱地冲进办公室。其中一个人向安迪露了屁股。梅雷迪思跳到了格伦身上。哦。是的。他没有抱她。梅雷迪思只是想加入派对。好吧，达里尔的前妻贾斯汀打电话给他，祝贺他中彩票。
But Daryl has to explain he wasn't part of the lottery pool anymore because of his promotion. He doesn't participate. So now she would like Glen's number. He's like, oh, I have it right here, click. This starts Daryl down a dark road. This is where he explains that they won playing his birthday. Yeah. Could you even imagine?
但达里尔不得不解释说，因为他升职了，所以他不再参与彩票合买池了。他不参与了。所以现在她想要格伦的电话号码。他说，哦，我这正好有，点击。这让达里尔走上了一条黑暗的道路。在这里他解释说他们是用他的生日买的中奖号码。对。你能想象吗？
No. That would sting. That would sting a little bit. You know, this cracked me up, Jenna, because there's been time to time that, you know, people go and get a lottery ticket, you know, like it hits a big number and the kids are like, this is kind of fun and we just get one. And we always play our birthdays or anniversary. It's so common.
不。那可真够刺痛人的。那可真是有点扎心。你知道，这让我笑翻了，珍娜，因为时不时地，你知道，大家会去买张彩票，你知道的，比如奖金池累积到一个巨额数字，孩子们就会说：“这挺有意思的，我们就买一张吧。”我们总是用我们的生日或纪念日。这太常见了。
It's very common. We never win. And I was really curious. Do most people play birthdays and anniversaries and special numbers? And I started Googling and, oh my goodness. What? Lady, just the world of lottery and the numbers. It is fascinating.
非常普遍。我们从来没中过。我当时真的很好奇。大多数人是不是都买生日、纪念日和特殊数字？于是我开始用谷歌搜索，天哪。什么？女士们，仅仅是彩票和数字的世界。太着迷了。
It is fascinating. You could do a whole podcast called Lottery, really. It's just so cool. I found out that there are websites that track the lottery numbers that are pulled the most and you got to hear this. According to an article written by Emily DeNuzo for Reader's Digest Magazine in February of this year, this article talked about lotteries that you can play anywhere in the U.S., you know, because there's also state lotteries.
太令人着迷了。你甚至可以做一个专门叫《彩票》的播客。太酷了。我发现有些网站会追踪最常被摇出的彩票号码，你得听听这个。根据艾米莉·德努佐今年2月为《读者文摘》杂志撰写的一篇文章，这篇文章探讨了你可以在美国任何地方玩的彩票（因为还有州立彩票，
That's the whole other thing. But according to USA Mega, here are the numbers most commonly drawn in the Mega Million. Ready? Wait, these are the most common winning numbers that are drawn? Yeah. Not necessarily all together, but these are the numbers that hit the most. Ready? I'm going to get a pen and some paper.
那是完全另一回事）。但根据USA Mega的数据，以下是超级百万（Mega Millions）中最常被摇出的号码。准备好了吗？等等，这些是最常被摇出的中奖号码吗？对。不一定全都在一起，但这些是命中率最高的号码。准备好了吗？我要拿支笔和纸。
I'm going to write these down. Look, I wrote them down for us and after this podcast today, I'm going to go get us a lottery ticket. This is awesome. Okay. Ready? Yes. 22, 11, 9, 10, 4, and 19, 22 was drawn 26 times and 11 was drawn 24 times.
我要把这些记下来。看，我帮我们记下来了，今天录完这个播客后，我要去给我们买张彩票。这太棒了。好了。准备好了吗？是的。22、11、9、10、4和19。22被摇出过26次，11被摇出过24次。
Now this is a survey over an extended period of time, over a few years, right? Okay. Several other of the most common Mega Million numbers were drawn 18 times. These numbers are 13, 14, 17, 18, 24, and 25. 13, 17, and 24 are numbers I always play in the Mega Million. Those were like my favorite numbers. Remember them for the Mega. Meanwhile, stay clear of 21, 45, 55, and 51 when choosing your first five numbers.
现在这是一项跨越较长时间（几年时间）的调查，对吧？对。超级百万中其他几个最常出现的号码被摇出过18次。这些数字是13、14、17、18、24和25。13、17和24是我在玩超级百万时总是买的号码。那些就像是我的幸运数字。记住它们，为了Mega。同时，在选择前五个号码时，要避开21、45、55和51。
Why? Because they never get picked. They're not as popular. This is so weird because it's obviously totally random. Every number has an equal opportunity to pop up. So it is fascinating to me that there are certain numbers that pop up so much more than others. Yes.
为什么？因为它们从来不被选中。它们没那么受欢迎。这太奇怪了，因为这显然完全是随机的。每个数字出现的几率都是一样的。所以让我着迷的是，为什么有些数字比其他数字出现的频率高得多。是的。
And listen, most people that win, 70% of people that win the lottery did where the computer picks for you. Do you know what I mean? Really? Yes. 70% of winners didn't even pick their own numbers. So it is incredibly random, but this is what some data is showing, and I'm sharing it. This is fascinating to me.
听着，大多数中奖的人，70%中彩票的人都是让电脑帮他们机选的。你知道我的意思吗？真的吗？是的。70%的中奖者甚至都没有自己选号。所以这绝对是随机的，但这就是一些数据显示的结果，我把它分享出来。这让我太着迷了。
It's making me think that there's something in the balls. There's maybe a little, the way the balls were made, the 69 ball. I don't know that there's a conspiracy, but... I'm not saying anybody planned it. I'm just saying maybe it happened. Maybe they're slightly just ever so like a millimeter smaller or something. I don't know. Or bigger.
这让我觉得球里面有猫腻。也许有点，做球的方式，69号球。我不是说有人在策划阴谋，但是……我不是说任何人计划了这件事。我只是说也许它发生了。也许它们稍微比标准的轻或小了一毫米左右。我不知道。或者大一点。
I don't know. I don't know. Has anyone measured them? I don't know. Jenna, have you ever known anyone that's won the lottery? Like really won? Not like just like $2 or something? No.
我不知道。我不知道。有人量过它们吗？我不知道。珍娜，你认识中过彩票的人吗？我是说真正中大奖的那种？不是只中2美元什么的？没有。
Okay. Are you ready for this? Do you? I know that I bring up 1-800-DENYST a lot. I know. But guess what? A lot happened there, and after I left being an operator, one of the operators that was still there that I knew won the lottery.
好吧。你准备好听这个了吗？你知道吗？我知道我经常提到“1-800-DENYST”。我知道。但你猜怎么着？那里发生了不少事，在我辞去话务员工作后，还在那里工作的一位我认识的话务员中了彩票。
How much? $120 million. What? What? What? $120 million? Yes. Yes, Jenna.
多少？1.2亿美元。什么？什么？什么？1.2亿美元？是的。没错，珍娜。
She was an inspiring actress working at 1-800-DENYST like so many of us because they had good hours if you wanted to audition. She played the lottery, and her and another person who she didn't know won. So they split it, they each got $60 million, which I guess after taxes is $30 million, but oh my gosh. And I saw her a few years ago. We have mutual friends from our time working as operators, and they had a Halloween party. I was at their Halloween party, and there she was.
她曾是一名怀揣演员梦想的女孩，和其他许多人一样在“1-800-DENYST”工作，因为如果你想去试镜，那里的工作时间很好。她买彩票了，她和另一个她不认识的人一起中了。所以他们平分了奖金，每个人分到了6000万美元，我猜扣除税后是3000万美元，但是哦天哪。几年前我还见过她。我们有共同的朋友，都是从前当话务员时认识的，他们办了一个万圣节派对。我在他们的万圣节派对上，她就在那儿。
And I was like, oh my gosh, how are you doing? She's doing great. She bought a farm. She has like a, you know, I think she grows avocados or avocado oil. Yeah. Can you imagine? No. I wouldn't want to win that amount of money.
当时我就想，哦天哪，你最近怎么样？她过得很好。她买了个农场。她好像有个，你知道的，我记得她种牛油果或者生产牛油果油。是的。你能想象吗？不。我才不想中那么多钱呢。
I don't want that responsibility. Yeah. Well, you know we have an office crossover to the lottery kind of, which is Jeff Blitz, our director who we love, did a documentary about lotto winners. It's so good. It's called Lucky. It came out in 2010. I started rewatching it.
我可不想要那种责任。是的。好吧，你知道我们有一部《办公室》和彩票有点交叉的作品，就是杰夫·布里茨，我们深爱的导演，拍过一部关于乐透中奖者的纪录片。太棒了。片名叫《幸运》（Lucky）。于2010年上映。我开始重新看它。
You can find it on Amazon Prime. It is so fascinating. It follows different people, winners of the lottery, losers of the lottery, people that play numbers all the time. It's very good. It is an amazing, amazing documentary. Yeah. But kind of like what you were saying, there's some people that are like the pressure of
你可以在亚马逊Prime上找到它。太迷人了。它追踪了不同的人，彩票中奖者、彩票失意者、经常买彩票的人。非常棒。这是一部极其、极其精彩的纪录片。是的。但就像你刚才说的，有些人会觉得
winning that, you know, it completely can derail their life. Some people know, but it's just very fascinating, all of it. Well, here's the thing. I did a whole deep dive on the lottery as well. I hate to bog everybody down with more lottery facts, but in this next scene, everybody starts discussing kind of what they would do if they won the lottery. Everybody's fantasizing about it. Everybody wishes it was them.
中奖带来的压力，你知道的，完全会毁了他们的生活。有些人懂的，但这一切都非常迷人。好吧，事情是这样的。我也对彩票做了一番深入研究。我讨厌用更多彩票冷知识来烦大家，但在接下来的这一场戏里，大家开始讨论如果中彩票会做什么。所有人都在幻想。每个人都希望中奖的是自己。
Yeah. I called this the scene of sass and belly itching. Please explain. Well, at three minutes and 21 seconds, I'm standing behind Dwight and I just am scratching that fake precker belly because it was so itchy and I am futzing with it through the whole scene. Well, we had a fan catch from Kaylee in Indianapolis who had a wardrobe catch for this scene. Everyone is in purple.
是的。我把这场戏称为“傲慢与肚皮发痒”的一场戏。请解释一下。好吧，在3分21秒时，我站在德怀特身后，我一直在挠那个假的普雷克肚皮，因为太痒了，整场戏我都在摆弄它。好吧，我们收到了来自印第安纳州凯利的粉丝捕捉，她发现了这场戏的一个服装穿帮。每个人都穿着紫色。
Phyllis, Angela, Kelly, Oscar, Erin and Meredith are all wearing purple in this scene. So you can add purple to your sass belly scratch observation. Okay. Well, the sass starts with Pam. She says to Jim, you know, he's explaining what he would do. He would, you know, live in Maine and bike or kayak to work or work at a bike shop and kayak. Anyway, lots of biking and kayaking.
菲莉丝、安吉拉、凯利、奥斯卡、埃伦和梅雷迪思在这场戏里都穿着紫色。所以你可以把紫色加入到你的“傲慢与挠肚皮”观察中。好吧。傲慢从帕姆开始。她对吉姆说，你知道的，他正在解释他中奖后会做什么。他会，你知道的，住在缅因州，骑自行车或划皮划艇去上班，或者在自行车店工作然后划皮划艇。总之，有很多骑车和划船活动。
And Pam says, and then on the weekends, would you hacky sack back to reality and spend time with your wife and kids? Mm-hmm. Ding. Second sass. Next sass. Jim sass. He says, whoa, saucy.
然后帕姆说：“然后到了周末，你会打着沙包回到现实，花时间陪你的妻子和孩子吗？”嗯哼。叮。第二次傲慢。接下来的傲慢。吉姆的傲慢。他说：“哇，真刻薄。”
And then we have some good old Ryan sass because Pam says she wants to live in a townhouse in Soho. And Ryan says, Soho's mostly lofts, but okay. I loved that line. I also noticed how it's Pam's dream to one day live in New York and it's my dream too. I wrote that down. I wrote that down. I said, Jenna, this is you and Pam are aligned in this moment, although Pam brings back her
然后我们还有一些经典的瑞恩式傲慢，因为帕姆说她想住在苏荷区（SoHo）的一栋联排别墅里。瑞恩说：“苏荷区大多是阁楼，不过好吧。”我太喜欢那句台词了。我还注意到，有一天住在纽约是帕姆的梦想，这也是我的梦想。我把它写下来了。我把它写下来了。我说：“珍娜，你和帕姆在这个时刻不谋而合，尽管帕姆重新带回了她的……
dream of having a terrace. She does. She needs to have like a balcony off of her townhouse slash loft apartment in New York. Yeah. I remember in Boys and Girls, she wanted the terrace. Yes. Well, what's really funny about this is that I did not have the dream of retiring in New York when we shot this episode.
梦想拥有一个露台。她有。她需要有一个类似她位于纽约的联排别墅加阁楼公寓的露台。对。我记得在《少男少女》里，她想要那个露台。是的。嗯，这个特别搞笑的一点是，我们在拍这集时，我并没有在纽约退休的梦想。
So I have only later in life had this in common with Pam. Yeah. Well, there's still more sass to come because now Meredith is going to say, good, a divorce. Good, a divorce. Yes. Well, here's the thing I got curious about. And it was a little bit because I remembered that documentary that you mentioned that Jeff Blitz did is winning the lottery really a good thing for your life.
所以我是在生活的后期才和帕姆有这个共同点的。是的。好吧，还有更多的讽刺要来，因为现在梅雷迪思要说，好，离婚。好，离婚。是的。嗯，这就是让我好奇的地方。这有点是因为我记起了你提到过的杰夫·布里茨拍的那部纪录片，中彩票对你的生活来说真的是一件好事吗？
Hmm. Yeah. And according to an article on moneymarshmallow.com titled, Why do lottery winners go broke? Winning the lottery does not sound great. It's been reported that 70% of lottery winners lose all of their money, all of their money, their winnings plus all the money they already had within five years of winning. Wow. So many of them go bankrupt and they believe it's for the following reasons, one, lack
嗯。是的。根据 moneymarshmallow.com 上一篇题为《为什么彩票中奖者会破产？》的文章，中彩票听起来并不是件好事。据报道，70%的彩票中奖者在赢得彩票后的五年内会输光他们所有的钱，所有的钱，他们的奖金加上他们本来就有的所有钱。哇。他们中的许多人破产了，他们认为原因如下，第一，
of money management skills, two, treating your lottery winnings as quote, free money. And so rather than spend it on things like paying off your debt or other bills, you do sort of like lavish, spontaneous spending like vacations, car. Yeah. Exactly. Also, and the warehouse workers should listen to this one. The most common reason people go broke in five years after winning the lottery is because they quit their job without a new plan.
缺乏资金管理技能，第二，把你的彩票奖金当作所谓的“免费资金”。因此，与其把钱花在偿还债务或支付其他账单上，你不如进行一些奢侈、冲动的消费，比如度假、买车。对。没错。还有，仓库工人们应该听听这个。中彩票后五年内破产最常见的原因是，他们在没有新计划的情况下辞职了。
Also making bad investments and not properly accounting for taxes. Taxes that's a big one. Yeah. All right. That's it. That's what I learned about the lottery. And also can I give a shout out to my son who helped me deep dive the lottery and he typed it all into my document for me because of my broken shoulder and because I can't
还有进行糟糕的投资，以及没有正确计算税收。税收，这是一个大问题。是的。好了。就是这样。这就是我了解到的关于彩票的知识。另外，我能对我的儿子表示感谢吗，他帮我深入研究了彩票，因为我肩膀骨折而且我不能，他把这些全都帮我打进我的文档里了
type. He was so supportive. It was so sweet. He sat at my computer. How adorable. I know. How adorable is that? Andy is really getting frustrated because no one is working.
打字。他太支持我了。太贴心了。他坐在我的电脑前。太可爱了。我知道。有多可爱？安迪真的开始感到沮丧了，因为没有人工作。
They can't focus because of this warehouse crew winning the lottery and Daryl is totally checked out. He hasn't hired any new warehouse workers and Phyllis get ready for some Phyllis sass in a little bit of St. Louis. Yes. It's about to hit you. Go to five minutes, 13 seconds to five minutes, 16 seconds because Phyllis is going to say Arder.
由于这群仓库工人中了彩票，他们无法集中精力，达里尔完全心不在焉。他没有招收任何新的仓库工人，菲利斯，准备好迎接一点圣路易斯风格的菲利斯式的讽刺吧。是的。它马上就要冲击你了。转到5分13秒到5分16秒，因为菲利斯要说“Arder”（订单/订单发音）。
Angela, we had a fan catch from Miranda B in Florida who said the same thing. Yes, Miranda. She says, Andy, this is a seriously big Arder. Yes. So strong. Well Phyllis says, Daryl, I sent you an email about it and he says, I haven't read it four hour work week. Do you know what that is?
安吉拉，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州米兰达·B的粉丝来信，她也说了同样的话。是的，米兰达。她说，安迪，这是一个极其巨大的“Arder”。是的，太强烈了。嗯，菲利斯说，达里尔，我给你发了一封关于这个的电子邮件，而他说，我还没读过《每周工作4小时》。你知道那是什么吗？
That is a reference to a real book by Tim Ferriss called The Four Hour Work Week. Were you only work four hours for a whole entire week? Yes. How? All right. I'll tell you. I read it. I read this book, Angela, when we were daydreaming about reinventing our lives and creating new
那是对蒂姆·费里斯所著的一本名为《每周工作4小时》的真实书籍的引用。你一周只需工作四个小时？是的。怎么做？好吧。我来告诉你。安吉拉，当我俩梦想着重塑生活、为自己创造新的职业时，我读过这本书，
careers for ourselves where we worked the hours we wanted when we wanted. So here is a one sentence summary of the book. This is from an online review, quote, The Four Hour Work Week is the step-by-step blueprint to free yourself from the shackles of a corporate job, create a business to fund the lifestyle of your dreams and live like a millionaire without actually having to be one. So in the book, he encourages you to first think about the life you want, not the job you want. What life do you want?
在这个职业中，我们在我们想要的时候工作我们想要的个小时。所以这里是对这本书的一句话总结。这是来自一个在线评论的引用，“《每周工作4小时》是将你自己从一份公司工作的枷锁中解放出来的循序渐进的蓝图，创造一个企业来资助你梦想的生活，并像百万富翁一样生活，而实际上不必成为百万富翁。”所以在书中，他鼓励你首先去思考你想要的生活，而不是你想要的工作。你想要什么样的生活？
Do you want to be a person who can travel all the time? Do you want to be a person who lives in a little town in Italy? And then once you figure out what you want your life to look like, then he says, here's how you fund your life by doing as little work as possible so that life is first and then job is second. Interesting. That's sort of his come from. Okay.
你想成为一个可以一直旅行的人吗？你想成为一个住在意大利小镇的人吗？然后，一旦你想清楚了你想要的生活是什么样子的，接着他说，这就是你如何通过尽可能少地工作来资助你的生活，这样生活是第一位的，而工作是第二位的。有趣。这就是他的出身。好的。
I really enjoyed the book, but one of the things that he has in the book is that you only answer your emails for like a scheduled period of time. You don't check your email all day. It's like a little minutia thing. And that is why Daryl has not read his email from Phyllis is because he's following the advice in this book. Well, however, Daryl would have quit his job first. Like you can't do his concepts in a corporate job because obviously they're going to need
我真的很喜欢这本书，但他在书中的其中一点是，你只在一段预定的时间内回复你的电子邮件。你不会一整天都查看电子邮件。这就像是一个微不足道的小细节。这就是为什么达里尔没有读菲利斯发给他的邮件，因为他遵循了这本书中的建议。不过，无论如何，达里尔应该先辞职。就像你在公司里不能执行他的概念一样，因为显然他们会需要
you to work more than four hours a week. I recommend the book. I really liked it. You know, he also has a podcast and he did an interview with Jerry Seinfeld. That is one of my favorite Jerry Seinfeld interviews I've ever listened to. Really? Yeah. If you're looking to kind of reinvent your life or even just muse on the idea of reinventing
你每周工作超过四个小时。我推荐这本书。我真的很喜欢它。你知道，他还有一个播客，他采访了杰瑞·宋飞。那是我听过的我最喜欢的杰瑞·宋飞的采访之一。真的吗？是的。如果你正想重塑你的生活，或者仅仅是沉思重塑生活这个主意，
your life, it's a good place to start. Okay. What's your favorite one? New York Times bestseller. I'm going to check it out. I'm not done with my sass tracker. Oh, I'm so sorry. I didn't mean to get us off on that.
这是一个很好的起点。好的。你最喜欢哪一本？《纽约时报》畅销书。我要去看看。我还没说完我的讽刺追踪器呢。哦，非常抱歉。我不是故意把我们扯到那上面的。
Yeah, please, please don't interrupt my important sass tracker. You know, Andy says we're going to need a crew in the warehouse because Phyllis has got to fill her ardor and Aaron volunteers. No one else is volunteering, but Andy volunteers Kevin and we're going to have some Kevin sass. Kevin says, good old Kevin. He'll do anything. He'll do what I will not do a good job. So that's who's headed down to the warehouse, along with Dwight and Jim.
是的，请，请不要打扰我重要的讽刺追踪器。你知道的，安迪说我们需要在仓库里安排一些人手，因为菲利斯必须去完成她的“Arder”，而艾琳自愿去了。没有其他人自愿，但安迪让凯文自愿去了，我们将迎来一些凯文式的讽刺。凯文说，老好人凯文。他什么都愿意做。他会做我不会做的好工作。所以这就是要前往仓库的人，还有德怀特和吉姆。
And then we've got some classic Angela sass and maybe, maybe top 10 biggest smiles Angela's had in the whole series. You mean when she goes up to Pam at reception with the old clipboard, uh-huh. She's pranking Pam, you know, her big prigs, little prigs prank. Pam's like, oh, come on, this is a lottery pool. This isn't about guessing my baby's weight. And Angela just walks away and goes, again, I'm sorry, it's my mistake. So much Angela sass.
然后我们有一些经典的安吉拉式的讽刺，也许，也许是安吉拉在整个系列中露出的前十大最大微笑之一。你是说当她拿着旧剪贴板走到前台的帕姆那里时，嗯哼。她在对帕姆恶作剧，你知道的，她的大恶作剧、小恶作剧。帕姆说，哦，得了吧，这是个彩票池。这又不是在猜我宝宝的体重。而安吉拉只是走开说，再次抱歉，是我的错。满满的安吉拉式的讽刺。
Yes. Angela had written down on the lottery pool that she thought Pam was going to have a 14 pound baby. Yeah. Mm-hmm. You know what? In real life, my son, who was inside my belly for this scene when he was born, he was almost 10 pounds.
是的。安吉拉在彩票池上写下她认为帕姆会生下一个14磅重的婴儿。是的。嗯哼。你知道吗？在现实生活中，拍这场戏时还在我肚子里的我的儿子，他出生时差不多有10磅重。
He was two ounces shy of 10 pounds. Mm-hmm. He did not fit into newborn clothing. I know. The nurses brought him in and they were like, is this a three month old or a newborn? I was like, I don't know why he's so large. One of my favorite pictures is a picture of your son as a baby next to my daughter as a toddler and he's her size.
他离10磅只差两盎司。嗯哼。他穿不下新生儿的衣服。我知道。护士把他抱进来时说，这是三个月的婴儿还是新生儿？我说，我不知道他为什么这么大。我最喜欢的照片之一是你的儿子作为婴儿时和我女儿作为幼儿时的合影，他有她那么大。
I know. It's so cute. We put that in our book. I know. I love it. Well, next up, Andy's going to go into Darrell's office and Darrell is very despondent. He has a monologue about tacos, how his basement still smells like tacos and you can't get taco smell out of the air in a basement.
我知道。太可爱了。我们把它放进我们的书里了。我知道。我喜欢它。好吧，接下来，安迪要走进达里尔的办公室，达里尔非常沮丧。他有一段关于塔可（墨西哥卷饼）的独白，讲他的地下室闻起来仍然像塔可，而且你无法除掉地下室里塔可的气味。
It's a very heavy smell. I probably should not have wanted a taco during this speech. It makes them not sound very, I don't know, appetizing, but after this speech, I just wanted a taco. That's all I wanted. Did you get one? No. No.
这是一种很重的气味。在这个演讲期间，我可能不该想吃塔可。这让它们听起来不怎么，我不知道，开胃，但在这段演讲之后，我只想吃一个塔可。这就是我想要的全部。你买了一个吗？没有。没有。
And I've been thinking about it and I'm pretty sure I'm going to have a taco today. Well, I know it's such a random thing, all I can think about was tacos. Well, don't eat it in an enclosed space because noted. I don't want you to have a taco smell that lingers. Okay. But Andy is going to say, why don't we look at some applicants? I mean, we need a warehouse crew. Yeah.
我一直在想这件事，我非常确信我今天要吃个塔可。好吧，我知道这是一件很随机的事，我满脑子想的都是塔可。好吧，可别在封闭的空间里吃它，因为，记下了。我不希望你有挥之不去的塔可味。好的。但安迪要说，我们为什么不看看一些应聘者呢？我的意思是，我们需要一个仓库团队。对。
Yeah. But I don't know, Darrell is just despondent. Yeah. He's not being Darrell. Well, speaking of warehouse crew, our new warehouse crew of Jim and Dwight and Aaron and Kevin is going to get off to a real start, I guess, a jolt, a jolt. I have to call bulls*** on this scene. I'm calling bulls***.
对。但我不知道，达里尔就是很沮丧。是的。他不像达里尔了。好吧，说到仓库团队，由吉姆、德怀特、艾琳和凯文组成的新仓库团队要正式开工了，我想，会是一个震动，一个震动。我对这一幕必须得爆粗口了。我要爆粗口了。
I'm playing the card. Oh my goodness. Yeah. What is, why such strong feelings? Because I think Dwight, who owns a farm and probably has multiple tractors and other kind of big farm machinery would know how to drive a forklift and wouldn't drive it straight into a wall. So there you go.
我要亮出这张牌了。哦，天哪。是的。为什么，为什么会有这么强烈的感觉？因为我认为德怀特拥有一个农场，可能拥有多台拖拉机和其他大型农业机械，他应该知道怎么开叉车，而且不会直接把它开进墙里。所以就是这样。
I don't play it very often, but I'm playing my bulls*** card. We got a lot of fan mail about this scene. Did anyone else call bulls***? No one else called bulls***. And I have to say, Angela, I accept your bulls*** card. Thank you. I have no retort. I played it fairly.
我不经常亮出它，但我正在亮出我的“胡扯”牌。我们收到了很多关于这一幕的粉丝来信。还有其他人觉得这是胡扯吗？没有其他人觉得是胡扯。我必须说，安吉拉，我接受你的“胡扯”牌。谢谢。我无言以对。我出得很公正。
You did. I played it well. What was the fan mail flurry about? Well, first of all, Stephen M from Ann Arbor, Michigan, noticed that Dwight fastened his seatbelt on the forklift and said, why would a forklift need a seatbelt? How fast do forklifts go? Well guess what, Stephen? Forklifts always come equipped with seatbelts because they are considered a vehicle.
你确实出得很公正。粉丝来信的热潮是关于什么的？嗯，首先，来自密歇根州安娜堡的史蒂芬·M注意到德怀特在叉车上系了安全带，并说，为什么叉车需要安全带？叉车能开多快？嗯，猜怎么着，史蒂芬？叉车出厂时总是配备安全带，因为它们被视为一种车辆。
Now while forklifts tend to only go 10 miles an hour or less and many businesses actually set their forklifts at five miles an hour, many injuries and fatalities occur when forklift operators get crushed between the vehicle and the ground. If it falls over because they try to jump out, like the forklift is falling over and they try to jump out and then they get crushed. So if you're wearing a seatbelt, the idea is that it makes it harder for you to jump out of the forklift and therefore it keeps you safer in the event that it should tip over.
虽然叉车往往只开到每小时10英里或更慢，而且许多企业实际上将他们的叉车设定为每小时5英里，但当叉车操作员被夹在车辆和地面之间时，会发生许多伤害和死亡事故。如果它因为他们试图跳车而翻倒，就像叉车正在翻倒而他们试图跳车，然后他们就会被压碎。所以如果你系了安全带，这个想法就是它让你更难从叉车里跳出来，因此在它发生倾翻的情况下能让你更安全。
So if it tips over, you're strapped in. Yes. You might be awkwardly on your side, but then you can unstrap and crawl out once it's done crashing. Moral of the story, if you're ever in a forklift that's tipping over, don't try to jump out. Like your chance of injury is much higher. But that is why they have seatbelts. And then we had a couple of questions.
所以在它倾翻时，你被绑在里面。是的。你可能会尴尬地侧躺着，但一旦撞击结束，你就可以解开安全带爬出来。故事的道德警示是，如果你在翻倒的叉车里，千万不要试图跳车。因为你受伤的几率要高得多。但这就是为什么它们有安全带。然后我们有几个问题。
These are some folks that write in almost every week, HarmGenV from the Netherlands wanted to know, in order to drive the forklift, did Rainn Wilson have to get certified first or was it a stunt driver? Well Steve Burgess said, Rainn and all of the warehouse worker actors who drove the forklift had to be certified to drive it. People was very safety conscious and they would not allow anyone to drive the forklift who had not taken and passed a certification class. And also that is not a stunt driver, Rainn actually drove the forklift into the door.
这些是一些几乎每周都写信来的人，来自荷兰的哈姆根V想知道，为了开叉车，雷恩·威尔逊必须先获得认证吗，还是那是特技替身？嗯，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，雷恩和所有驾驶叉车的仓库工人演员都必须获得驾驶认证。剧组对安全非常有意识，绝不允许任何没有参加并通过认证课程的人驾驶叉车。而且那不是特技替身，雷恩真的把叉车开撞上了门。
Fakey door is a fakey door. Well now you're leading me perfectly into a fan question from Cameron C in California who we hear from a lot. Hi Cameron. Hi. Cameron would like to know, how did the forklift go through the door so easily? Can I guess what it was made of? Yes.
假门就是假门。好吧，你现在完美地把我引导到了加利福尼亚州卡梅伦·C的一个粉丝提问，我们经常收到他的来信。嗨，卡梅伦。嗨。卡梅伦想知道，叉车是怎么这么轻松地穿过那扇门的？我能猜猜它是用什么做的吗？可以。
Like a type of styrofoam? It was balsa wood. Steve Burgess said that Rainn really drove the forklift into the door and just the bottom part had been replaced with balsa wood. That way the top part would still like clang like a heavy door. We were prepared to do two takes but we only needed to do one. There you go. Dwight gets off the machine after he crashes it into the door and just calmly walks over
就像一种泡沫塑料？它是轻木做的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，雷恩确实把叉车开撞向了门，只有底部被换成了轻木。这样顶部依然会像沉重的门一样发出铿锵声。我们准备拍两场，但我们只拍了一场。你看。德怀特把叉车开撞上门后从机器上下来，然后平静地走过去，
and starts carrying the boxes by hand. Yes. I was very curious about what a box of ten reams of paper weighs which is about the size boxes that look like to me, the standard box you see you know. And I looked up a box of ten reams of paper and it says it weighs 20 pounds. So picking up a 20 pound box is the thing that they've been avoiding this whole episode. They're sliding across the floor 20 pound boxes. I mean I could see how after carrying several of those it gets trying and none of them are
开始用手搬运箱子。是的。我很好奇一箱十令纸有多重，也就是对我来说看起来像的那种尺寸的箱子，你在网上看到的标准箱子。我查了一下十令纸的箱子，上面说它重20磅。所以捡起一个20磅重的箱子就是他们这一整集一直在逃避的事情。他们在地板上滑行20磅重的箱子。我的意思是，我能看出在搬运了好几个这种箱子之后，它是多么令人疲惫，而且他们都没有
wearing those belts that the warehouse crew usually wears. Yeah, yeah, the lift, the belt, the thing that helps your back. Protects your back. Yeah. Well lady, Andy and Darryl are going to meet with a group of potential new warehouse workers but maybe we should take a break because I have some really fun finds about all these people we're about to meet. Oh good.
戴着仓库员工通常佩戴的那种腰带。对，对，那个吊带、腰带，那个能帮到你背部的东西。保护你的背部。是的。好吧，女士，安迪和达里尔将与一群潜在的新仓库员工会面，但也许我们应该休息一下，因为我关于我们要见的所有这些人有一些非常有趣的发现。哦，太好了。
Let's take a break and when we come back, let's meet the applicants. Well you guys, before we meet everyone interviewing for this new warehouse, I needed to show you and share with you a text exchange I had with Oscar Nunez. Okay. So you guys know to sort of commemorate the release of John Wick 4, Jenna, you and I both posted the Zoom video of you and I podcasting from our closets where I told you I had watched the John Wick movies and you said what are you talking about? Even though you had told me to watch them, we're not going to rehash it.
我们休息一下，等我们回来时，去见见应聘者。各位，在见到所有面试这个新仓库岗位的人之前，我需要向你们展示并分享一段我和奥斯卡·努涅斯的短信交流。好的。所以你们知道为了纪念《疾速追杀4》的上映，詹娜，你和我都发布了你和我从衣柜里进行播客的Zoom视频，当时我告诉你我看过《疾速追杀》电影，而你说你在说什么呢？尽管你曾叫我看它们，我们不会再重提了。
We won't. We won't. But yes. And I called on Sam to be my backup. Anyway, Oscar saw our Instagram post. You know, he's rarely on social media. He saw our Instagram post. He got so tickled by it that it led to this text exchange.
我们不会。我们不会。但是是的。我请求萨姆做我的后盾。不管怎样，奥斯卡看到了我们的Instagram帖子。你知道的，他很少上社交媒体。他看到了我们的Instagram帖子。他觉得太有趣了，以至于促成了这段短信交流。
Are you ready? Yes. Good morning, Angela. On Instagram, you and Jenna did a funny bit about watching John Wick. I want to comment on it but I can't find it now. How do I find it? So I texted him back and I said, you just go to Instagram and type in Angela Kinsey and you'll find it.
准备好了吗？是的。早安，安吉拉。在Instagram上，你和詹娜做了一个关于看《疾速追杀》的搞笑片段。我想评论它，但我现在找不到了。我怎么找到它？所以我回短信告诉他，你只要去Instagram输入安吉拉·金西就能找到了。
And then he wrote back, okay. So then I gave it a few minutes and I went to see what he posted. Okay. This is what he commented on our John Wick video. Ready? Angela Kinsey, hashtag flashback Friday to Ms. Jenna Fisher. It is his pitch for John Wick 5. John Wick 5, Healing and Forgiveness, written and directed by Jenna Fisher.
然后他回信说，好的。所以我等了几分钟，去看看他发布了什么。好的。这是他在我们的《疾速追杀》视频下的评论。准备好了吗？安吉拉·金西，#闪回星期五致敬詹娜·费舍尔女士。这是他为《疾速追杀5》构思的提案。《疾速追杀5：治愈与宽恕》，詹娜·费舍尔编剧并导演。
The movie takes place on Nantucket, where John Wick is a proprietor of a small shop that sells porcelain coffee mugs and towels. It's called Drink and Dry. John Wick changes the dressing on his many wounds, visiting the doctor to make sure his stitches are removed properly and scarring is at a minimal. He learns to write in beautiful cursive old English. He mails poems and coffee related items to the Russian mafia. They open his quiet thoughtful gifts in their loud, garish raves and toss them in the garbage.
电影发生在楠塔基特岛，约翰·威克是一家出售瓷制咖啡杯和小毛巾的小店的老板。店名叫“喝吧擦干”。约翰·威克正在为他身上的多处伤口换药，拜访医生以确保他的缝合线被正确拆除并且疤痕减到最少。他学会了用漂亮的花体老式英语书写。他给俄罗斯黑手党寄去诗歌和与咖啡相关的物品。他们在他们嘈杂、俗气的狂欢中打开他安静体贴的礼物，然后把它们扔进垃圾桶。
Pearls to swine. One time John Wick stumbles on a stair but quickly catches himself. Oh thank goodness. He walks along the beach and meets a woman wrapped in a cardigan with long white hair. She doesn't dye it because she doesn't play games. They kiss ever so gingerly. He pulls back because his lip is still a little busted up. They laugh quietly as they cradle piping mugs of coffee, the end.
明珠暗投。有一次约翰·威克在楼梯上绊了一下，但很快稳住了自己。哦，谢天谢地。他沿着海滩散步，遇到了一位身披开衫、留着长白发的妇女。她不染发，因为她不玩游戏。他们轻轻地吻了一下。他退了回来，因为他的嘴唇还是有点破了。他们一边轻轻地笑着，一边捧着冒热气的咖啡杯，剧终。
Keanu Reeves stunt double is Angela Kinsey. I got so tickled so then I texted him and I said oh my gosh Oscar your comments are hilarious. And he said well you ladies made me laugh so much I just ran with it. I need that movie. After seeing John Wick 4 I need a whole two hours where he just heals and sips warm coffee. I love it. And falls in love. Yes.
基努·里维斯的特技替身是安吉拉·金西。我觉得太搞笑了，所以我给他发短信说，哦天哪，奥斯卡，你的评论太搞笑啦。他说，嗯，你们女士把我逗得太厉害了，我顺着思路就写下去了。我需要那部电影。看完《疾速追杀4》后，我需要整整两个小时看他只是疗伤和啜饮温热的咖啡。我喜欢它。还有坠入爱河。是的。
I love this idea. Thank you Oscar. All right. Should we get back to this episode? Yes. Let's meet the warehouse interviewees. Well they're in the conference room and immediately Daryl tells everybody in the room that the last warehouse workers won the lottery and quit.
我喜欢这个主意。谢谢你，奥斯卡。好了。我们该回到这集节目中了吗？是的。让我们见见仓库面试者。好吧，他们在会议室里，达里尔立即告诉房间里的所有人，上一批仓库工人中了彩票然后辞职了。
Yeah. He's not pitching working at Dundramiflin like at all. Like he's like you know what think long and hard about it because you know you're going to get here then you're going to get stuck then you're going to you know your life is over and what what do you have to show for it. Well we got some fan questions. Allie from Topeka Kansas wrote in to say during the conference room interview at eight minutes and 30 seconds Mike E. Winfield is in the scene.
是的。他一点也没有在推销在邓德米夫林工作这件事。就像是他会说，你知道吗，好好考虑清楚，因为你知道你来到这里，然后你就会被困住，然后你就会，你知道，你的人生就完了，你有什么可炫耀的。好吧，我们有一些粉丝提来自堪萨斯州托皮卡的艾莉写信说，在会议室面试期间，在8分30秒时，迈克·E·温菲尔德出现在镜头里。
He is now a stand up comedian and my fiance and I saw a couple of his shows on a cruise last January. He is so funny and I am curious if the office was one of his first gigs. I would really love a mom detective's deep dive on him. Well yes Allie that is Mike E. Winfield. He has been a stand up comedian for over 20 years or so and he became really famous because he was a finalist on America's Got Talent in 2022 but he did not win and he was super crushed but then he got to go on to be an all star finalist in 2023.
他现在是一名单口喜剧演员，去年1月我和未婚夫在游轮上看过他的几场演出。他太搞笑了，我很好奇《办公室》是不是他的第一份工作之一。我真的很想让妈妈侦探对他的背景做一次深入挖掘。好吧，是的，艾莉，那是迈克·E·温菲尔德。他当单口喜剧演员已经20年左右了，他成名是因为他是2022年《美国达人秀》的决赛选手，但他没有赢，他超级沮丧，但后来他得以参加2023年的全明星决赛。
I went to his website. He's so funny so charming and according to his IMDB page he had done one project before the office. It was the Bobby Lee project which I believe was a pilot and that was a few years before he got his role in the office and guess what? He's going to be back. He does another episode coming up. That's a good deep dive.
我去了他的网站。他太有趣了，太迷人了，根据他的IMDB页面，在拍《办公室》之前他做过一个项目。那是《鲍比·李计划》，我相信那是一个试播集，那是在他在《办公室》中获得角色几年前的事。你猜怎么着？他还会回来。他接下来还要客串另一集。这是一个很好的深度挖掘。
I thought it was pretty good. Thanks. Well you know who else is in that room. Amina. Yes. Amina Kaplan. She's the one woman in the conference room and you do not realize it from this episode but Amina is going to have quite the arc coming up in season eight.
我觉得挺不错的。谢谢。好吧，你知道那个房间里还有谁。阿米娜。是的。阿米娜·卡普兰。她是会议室里的那个女性，你在这集中可能看不出来，但阿米娜在第八季中将有一个相当丰满的人物弧光。
She's going to appear in 14 episodes. Yep. As Val. Spoiler alert. We have to have Amina on. We do because their romance is brewing. I know. She was the loveliest.
她将出现在14集里。是的。饰演瓦尔。剧透警告。我们得请阿米娜上节目。我们必须请，因为他们的浪漫情愫正在酝酿。我知道。她是最可爱的人。
So sweet. Yeah. Well as her storyline develops we'll get her on the pod. I have such fond memories of being on set with her. Well Daryl doesn't know that romance is in his future. He's still very much down in the dumps and he has a talking head where he says he's never been lucky and he doesn't just mean the lottery. He developed a soy allergy at 35.
太甜了。是的。好吧，随着她的剧情线发展，我们会请她上播客的。我和她一起在片场的记忆太美好了。好吧，达里尔不知道浪漫在等着他。他仍然非常沮丧，他有一段独白说他从来没有走运过，他指的不仅仅是彩票。他在35岁时患上了大豆过敏。
Yes. Why is soy in everything? Yeah. I looked it up. You looked up why soy is in everything? Yeah. It's in everything because it helps keep food moist. Oh.
是的。为什么每样东西里都有大豆？是的。我查了一下。你查了为什么每样东西里都有大豆？是的。每样东西里都有它，因为它有助于保持食物湿润。哦。
Yeah. It's like a moist. Moist catalyst. We had a fan question from Teresa M. in London, Ontario, Canada who said, I am curious. Is there a story behind this soy allergy at the age of 35? As someone who developed a soy allergy at 25 it has always made me laugh. I was curious too. I was really curious.
对。它就像是一个湿润剂。湿润催化剂。我们收到了来自安大略省伦敦市的特蕾莎·M的粉丝提问，她说，我很好奇。35岁患上大豆过敏背后有什么故事吗？作为一个在25岁时患上大豆过敏的人，这总是让我发笑。我也很好奇。我真的很好奇。
I was like, did one of the writers develop a soy allergy? Did you find this out Jenna? Well I reached out to Charlie Grandy who wrote this episode and he said it's not based on his personal experience. In fact he's pretty sure that it was Paul who pitched that joke. Does Paul have a soy allergy? I didn't get a chance to reach out to him. Well I have some more sass for you.
我想，是哪个编剧得了大豆过敏吗？詹娜，你发现这个了吗？嗯，我联系了写这一集的查理·格兰迪，他说这不是根据他的个人经历改编的。事实上，他很确定是保罗提出了那个笑话。保罗对大豆过敏吗？我没机会联系他。好吧，我还有更多讽刺要带给你。
Oh yeah? Yeah. We're at reception. Pam is behind the desk and Ryan says, nice. Right back where I like you. Ryan. So much sass. He might win the sassiest of the episode.
哦，是吗？是的。我们在前台。帕姆坐在办公桌后，瑞安说，真好。又回到我喜欢你的地方了。瑞安。满满的讽刺。他可能会赢得本集的“讽刺之王”。
Well Pam's going to give him some sass back. She's not going to take that. No. Ryan notices that Pam is trying to maybe buy a lottery ticket online and he's like oh yeah everyone wants to be rich without working for it. And that's when Pam sasses and reminds him that he got to work at 10.30 this morning. And he drops it. He's like retreat, retreat.
好吧，帕姆要回敬他一些讽刺。她可不会逆来顺受。没有。瑞安注意到帕姆可能正试图在网上买彩票，他说，哦，是的，每个人都想不劳而获地变得富有。就在那时，帕姆进行了讽刺，并提醒他今天10点半才来上班。他退缩了。他说，撤退，撤退。
I personally loved getting to sit behind the reception desk again. It was so fun. Oh I didn't even think about that. Be back at my old haunt. Did you feel like you were back home a little bit? A little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
我个人很喜欢重新坐在前台桌子后面。太有趣了。哦，我甚至都没想到这一点。回到我以前常去的地方。你觉得有点像回家了吗？有一点。对。对。
The desk still hit my knees in an awkward way. Yeah. Just how you liked it. It was an awkward height, that desk. Well back in the conference room, Andy is now in charge doing the interview process with the warehouse people because Darrell bailed and it's a hot mess. He wants to know if they have a degree or in warehouse sciences possibly and Val is like are you serious?
那张桌子还是以一种尴尬的方式撞到我的膝盖。对。正如你所喜欢的。那张桌子的高度很尴尬。好吧，回到会议室，因为达里尔当了逃兵，安迪现在负责带着仓库的人进行面试流程，这简直是一团糟。他想知道他们是否有学位，或者可能拥有仓库科学学位，而瓦尔的反应是，你是认真的吗？
Listen, speaking of a hot mess down in the warehouse, these guys cannot move paper. I mean it's really ridiculous. But Kevin's going to come up with this idea. He remembered how his sisters used to butter him up and slide him across the floor. Yeah, the linoleum. Yes. But Jim and Dwight kind of shoot this idea down and then Erin. Oh my gosh.
听着，说到仓库里的一团糟，这些人根本搬不动纸。我的意思是，这真的很荒谬。但凯文想出了这个主意。他记得他的姐姐们过去是如何抹上黄油然后让他在地板上滑行的。是的，油毡地。是的。但吉姆和德怀特有点否定了这个主意，然后是艾琳。哦，天哪。
Oh my gosh. So funny. She laughed so hard when she grabs him by the arm and says, drop it. Drop it. They don't like it. I like it. But they don't like it. So drop it.
哦，天哪。太搞笑了。当她抓住他的胳膊说“放下。放下”时，她笑得前仰后合。他们不喜欢。我喜欢。但他们不喜欢。所以放下。
So funny. Where did that come from? I don't know. She's so funny in this episode though. I know. Well, you know, all of those potential warehouse workers upstairs, they have left. So now Andy has to find a whole new crew of applicants. He's going to start by asking Oscar, who is the strongest person in Scranton?
太搞笑了。这从哪儿冒出来的？我不知道。不过她在这一集里太搞笑了。我知道。好吧，你知道，楼上那些潜在的仓库工人，他们都走了。所以现在安迪不得不寻找一整批新的应聘者。他首先问奥斯卡，斯克兰顿最强壮的人是谁？
And Oscar immediately says Bruce Kenwood works out at Planet Fitness. Well, I like that his first thing is bulk or definition. Yes. Like what's true? What do you want? I looked up to see if there was a Planet Fitness in Scranton and there is. Yes. But there is not a Gold's Gym.
奥斯卡立刻说布鲁斯·肯伍德在Planet Fitness健身。嗯，我喜欢他的第一反应是看重肌肉块还是肌肉线条。是的。就像什么是真的？你想要什么？我查了一下斯克兰顿有没有Planet Fitness，确实有。是的。但没有Gold's Gym。
There was, but it's closed. Oh, okay. There you go. So Andy is going to find three new fellas to interview. And one of them is Nate, one of them is Gideon, and one is Bruce Kenwood, the buff guy. Yes. We start with Gideon. Gideon was played by Barrick Hardley.
曾经有过，但关门了。哦，好吧。就是这样。所以安迪要寻找三个新的家伙来面试。其中一个是内特，一个是吉迪恩，还有一个是布鲁斯·肯伍德，那个肌肉男。是的。我们从吉迪恩开始。吉迪恩由巴拉克·哈德利饰演。
He's a comedic actor. He's been in a ton of stuff studied at UCB. He has a website called BarrickHardley.com. I spent so much time on this website, Angela. Really? In addition to being a performer, he is also an artist, and he makes and sells these handmade vintage light boxes. So like a little wooden box, and then it has a little button and a light turns on it.
他是一名喜剧演员，演过大量作品，在UCB（Upright Citizens Brigade）学习过。他有一个名为 BarakHardley.com 的网站。安吉拉，我在这个网站上花了好多时间。真的吗？除了是一名表演者，他还是一个艺术家，他制作并出售这些手工制作的复古灯箱。就像一个小木盒，上面有一个小按钮，按一下灯就会亮。
It'll say like on air, or it'll say like meeting and progress. You can get them custom made. They'll say anything you want. We need one. We need one that says awesome ladies. I know. I want to order one. Oh my gosh.
上面会写着“正在播出”（on air），或者会写着“会议进行中”（meeting and progress）。你可以定制它们。它们可以写任何你想写的话。我们需要一个。我们需要一个写着“超棒的女士们”的。我知道。我想订一个。哦，天哪。
His work is beautiful. He also has like amazing sculpted art. He's so talented. He also wrote a movie that he stars in called Spell. I watched a trailer for it. The lead character that he plays goes to Iceland, and Lady, Lady. What? He goes to the Icelandic Penis Museum.
他的作品太美了。他还拥有令人惊叹的雕塑艺术。他太有才了。他还写了一部由他主演的名为《咒语》（Spell）的电影。我看过它的预告片。他饰演的主角去了冰岛，然后，女士，女士。什么？他去了冰岛阴茎博物馆。
No. You see it. Yes. No. He must have shot at the Penis Museum. I mean, you know, I imagine them being accommodating. They sound very friendly on their website. Well, Barak, we are going to be placing an order for an office ladies handmade light
不会吧。你看到了。是的。不会吧。他一定是在那个阴茎博物馆拍摄的。我的意思是，你知道的，我想象他们会很通融。他们的网站听起来非常友好。好吧，巴拉克，我们打算订购一个“办公室女士”手工制作的灯箱。
box. But seriously, guys, check out this website. I'm so like inspired and pressed and charmed by it. Barak, it's B-A-R-A-K, last name hardly, H-A-R-D-L-E-Y dot com. I'll put it in our stories too. Great. Barak, also hear me out here. Maybe you could come on and tell us all about the Penis Museum.
但说真的，伙计们，去看看这个网站吧。我太受启发、印象深刻并被它迷住了。巴拉克，是 B-A-R-A-K，姓氏是哈德利，H-A-R-D-L-E-Y 点 com。我也会把它发到我们的快拍里。太棒了。巴拉克，也听听我的意见。也许你可以来给我们讲讲关于阴茎博物馆的一切。
Right? Yes. I mean, you went all the way to Iceland. We want to hear about it. All right. So the other person in the room who isn't Nate is Bruce Kenward. He is the guy in the tank top. We got a fan question from Dotty D in San Francisco, California, who wants to know what does the
对吧？是的。我的意思是，你一路去了冰岛。我们想听听。好吧。所以房间里除了内特之外的另一个人是布鲁斯·肯伍德。他是那个穿背心的家伙。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州旧金山市的达蒂·D的粉丝提问，她想知道群面时
guy's shirt say in the group interview? It's been driving me crazy for years. Yes. He's wearing a shirt and it's like pixelated. Yeah. He made it, you guys. He made it himself. Yeah.
那个家伙的衬衫上写的是什么？这多年来一直把我快逼疯了。是的。他穿着一件衬衫，而且上面是像素化的。是的。伙计们，这是他自己做的。他自己做的。是的。
Steve Burgess said it was scripted. And we made that shirt for him to wear and it was always from the very beginning intended to be blurred. So I believe you pulled the character description from the script, which includes the notation for the t-shirt. Yes. This is exactly how it was written in the script. Andy interviews his new candidates, Nate, a bearded hipster, Gideon, and Bruce Kenward,
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说那是剧本里写好的。我们为他制作了那件衬衫让他穿，从一开始它就注定是被打上马赛克的。所以我想你是从剧本中提取了角色描述，其中包含了对这件T恤的注释。是的。剧本里就是这么写的。安吉拉采访了他的新候选人，留着胡子的嬉皮士内特，吉迪恩，还有布鲁斯·肯伍德，
a buff built beautiful man wearing a tank top and flip flops. His tank top is pixelated on the front. It reads, my balls have biceps and my biceps have balls. There you go, Dotty. This isn't the only time we're going to talk about balls in this episode. I thought about naming it Sass and Balls, but I went with so much sass. We talk about balls again in this episode? Yes, we do.
一个身材健美、穿着背心和夹脚拖的美男子。他的背心正面是像素化的。上面写着：“我的蛋蛋有二头肌，我的二头肌有蛋蛋。”给你，达蒂。这并不是我们在这一集里唯一一次谈到蛋蛋。我曾考虑把它命名为《讽刺与蛋蛋》，但我最后选了《满满的讽刺》。我们在这一集里又谈到蛋蛋了吗？是的，我们谈到了。
I will wait for it. That's my ball tracker. I have a sass tracker and a ball tracker. It was a busy episode for me. What is your life? What is your life? What is my life? Well, Bruce Kenward was played by Jason Walsh, and according to his IMDB, he was born in
我会拭目以待的。那是我的“蛋蛋追踪器”。我有一个讽刺追踪器和一个蛋蛋追踪器。对我来说这是忙碌的一集。你过的是什么生活？你过的是什么生活？我过的是什么生活？好吧，布鲁斯·肯伍德由杰森·沃尔什饰演，根据他的IMDB，他出生在
Missouri. Oh, and this is his only on-camera credit. He is a trainer and he has trained some very big name actors for very big name movie roles. He has worked with Matt Damon several times, for example, on the Jason Bourne movie as well as The Great Wall, but he was also a trainer for Brie Larson on Captain Marvel and was one of Bradley Cooper's trainers for American Sniper. Bradley Cooper had more than one trainer. Okay, this is a total tangent, but since you brought up The Great Wall that Matt Damon
密苏里州。哦，这是他唯一的出镜演出的演职员表。他是一名健身教练，曾为一些非常大牌的演员在非常大牌的电影角色中进行过训练。例如，他曾多次与马特·达蒙合作，包括《谍影重重》系列电影以及《长城》，但他也曾是《惊奇队长》中布丽·拉尔森的教练，并且是《美国狙击手》中布莱德利·库珀的教练之一。布莱德利·库珀不止一个教练。好吧，这是一个题外话，但既然你提到了马特·达蒙参演的《长城》。
was in. Yes. I just saw him interviewed and he was saying his teenage daughter likes to kind of mess with him. She doesn't want to watch Ineva's movies that are considered really, really great fine movies. She only wants to watch The Stinkers. I saw the Stinkers. He was talking about the wall and saying that she had seen the wall and he says, it's The
是的。我刚好看过对他的采访，他说他的十几岁的女儿喜欢拿他开玩笑。她不想看伊纳瓦（指马特·达蒙）那些被认为非常非常棒的优秀电影。她只想看烂片。我看过烂片。他在谈论《长城》时说她看过《长城》，而他说，这是《长城》。而她说，不，爸爸，爸爸，那部电影里没有什么伟大的地方。我只是觉得，作为一个现在有青少年的家长，青少年的讽刺，我真的很欣赏。那个故事把我逗乐了。
Great Wall. And she was like, no, dad, dad, there's nothing great about that movie. I just, as someone who has teenagers now, the teen sass, I really appreciated it. That story cracked me up. Well, listen, the final person in the room is Nate and he is going to explain to us that while he does not technically have a hearing problem, he does have trouble with people understanding certain sounds in certain situations. And we got a lot of mail about this.
好吧，听着，房间里的最后一个人是内特，他要向我们解释，虽然他在技术上没有听力问题，但他确实在某些情况下对某些声音的理解有困难。我们收到了很多关于这封信的邮件。这是一个真实存在的现象吗？是的，确实如此。嗯，如你所知，我妹妹有听力障碍。她两只耳朵都戴着助听器。她遇到的问题之一就是在大型群体情况或餐厅里辨别和理解单个单词。所以如果她坐在餐厅的大桌子旁，周围有很大的背景噪音，她很难专注于讲话者。
Is this a real thing? Yes, it is. Well, as you know, my sister is hearing impaired. She wears hearing aids in both ears. And one of the issues that she has is in deciphering and understanding individual words in large group situations or like at restaurants. So if she's sitting at a big table in a restaurant and there's a lot of background noise, it's really hard for her to focus on the speaker.
现在，如果她是在你家里，坐在餐桌旁吃晚饭，就会容易得多，因为助听器的问题在于它们会同时放大所有声音。它们不仅仅放大讲话者，它们放大一切。所以它就变成了一大堆噪音。没错。现在，这并不是我们认为内特遇到的问题，但我们确实收到了来自佐治亚州道尔顿的杰克·希金斯医生的来信，他说，我是一名听力学家，每次我看到这一集，我都试图诊断内特的听力问题。
Now if she's in your house and she's sitting at a table for dinner, it's a lot easier because the problem with hearing aids is that they amplify all sound at once. They don't just amplify a speaker, they amplify everything. And so it just becomes a big bunch of noise. Right. Now that is not what we think Nate has a problem with, but we did get some mail from Dr. Jack Hitchens in Dalton, Georgia, who says, I'm an audiologist and every time I see this episode, I try to diagnose Nate's hearing problem.
他说，我相信内特可能有听觉处理障碍。这是一种病症，患者可以在基本的听力测试中正常检测到声音，但在大脑层面上将某些声音组合起来并理解其意义时会有困难。他说，内特也可能有听力损失而自己却不知道。这在某种程度上和我刚才讲的我妹妹的情况差不多。但我们收到了来自科罗拉多州丹佛市的卡罗尔·P的另一封信，她说，我相信内特所描述的是一种叫做听觉处理障碍的疾病，我本人就有这种病。
He said, I believe Nate might have an auditory processing disorder. It is a condition where someone can detect sounds normally on a basic hearing test but have difficulty combining and making sense out of certain sounds at the level of the brain. He said, Nate might also have hearing loss without knowing it. And that would sort of kind of lump into what I was saying about my sister. But we got another letter from Carol P and Denver, Colorado, who said, I believe what Nate is describing is a disorder called auditory processing disorder, which I have.
这并不是广为人知，这让我非常惊讶能在电视剧中看到它的表现。我实际上有一个朋友，她的女儿也有同样的疾病。所以听着，外面的朋友们。如果你遇到这种内特所描述的困难情况，去检查一下。这不仅仅是你的听力问题，因为你可以通过听力测试，但你可能仍然有这种听觉处理障碍，这使得你的大脑很难处理它所听到的声音。你可以做一些练习来改善这一点，让生活对你自己来说容易得多，顺便提一下。
It's not commonly known, which made me so surprised to see it represented in a TV show. And I actually have a friend whose daughter has this same disorder. Yeah. So listen, people out there. If you are ever in these situations where you're having this problem that Nate is describing, go get checked out. And it's not just your hearing, because you can take a hearing test and pass the hearing test.
我觉得这一切都非常有趣，如果不是你开始分享的话，我是不会想到这些的。好吧，我真的很感谢我们收到的大家的来信。我总是很高兴看到人们看到自己被代表。
But you might still have this auditory processing disorder, which makes it hard for your brain to process what it is hearing. And there's exercises you can do to improve this and make life a lot easier for yourself, throwing it out there. I find this all very interesting and something I wouldn't have thought about until you've started sharing it. Well, I really appreciated all the mail we got from people. And I always like it when people see themselves represented.
是的。这是一种真实的疾病，所以我认为把它提出来会很酷。是的。我很高兴你这么做了。回到仓库，他们终于决定采用凯文的计划了。他们要给地板润滑并把箱子滑向卡车。有一个被剪掉的场景，吉姆说，我真不敢相信仓库建好这么多年了，他们竟然只是把卡车倒车开进仓库。
Yeah. This is a real disorder. And so I thought it would be cool to bring it up. Yeah. I'm so glad you did. Back in the warehouse, they have finally decided to go with Kevin's plan, I guess. They're going to grease the floor and slide boxes to the truck. There was a deleted scene where Jim says, I can't believe in all the years the warehouse
然后你就可以轻松地装货了。所以他说，我们这么做吧。他让德怀特把车倒进去。但你很快就会意识到卡车太大了，车道太窄转不过弯来。是的。你转不过弯。德怀特擦到了仓库建筑物的侧面，把卡车卡住了。然后这就导致吉姆和德怀特觉得，好吧，我们试试滑行的方法吧。这就是为什么在镜头中，你现在可以看到卡车更近了。它有点楔进仓库里了。我注意到了这一点。是的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯在解析中提到了你刚才说的那个被剪掉的场景。
was here. They simply backed the truck up into the warehouse. And then you could just easily load it. So he's like, let's do this. And he has Dwight back it up. But what you realize really quickly is the truck is too big, the driveway is too narrow to turn in. Yeah.
雷恩确实把卡车开撞上了墙。雷恩为这一集亲自完成了所有的特技动作。那是一辆大卡车。他在这一集里非常像基努（里维斯）。是的，他确实很像。安吉拉，在这一集大约16分钟时的这个场景中，一堆箱子看起来像是冲向了摄像师。是的。
You can't make the turn. Dwight clips the side of the warehouse building and gets the truck stuck. And then that's what leads Jim and Dwight to be like, okay, let's try the slide method. And that's why in the shots, you can see now the truck is closer. It's kind of wedged into the warehouse. I did notice that. Yeah. Well, Steve Burgess had mentioned in his breakdown that deleted scene you just mentioned.
我记录的时间是16分43秒。看起来它撞倒了摄影师。来自堪萨斯州托皮卡的艾利·G想知道这是剧本安排的还是纯粹的意外事故。嗯，艾利，我也很好奇。我看了拍摄剧本。上面是这么写的。我们开始拍摄，吉姆和德怀特把一箱纸放在垃圾桶盖上，并在一个精加工的轨道上滑动它，
Rain really did drive the truck into the wall. Rain did all his own stunts for this episode. It's a big truck. He was very Keanu in this episode. Yes, he was. Well Angela, in this scene at around 16 minutes, a bunch of boxes look like they careen into the camera operator. Yeah.
但滑行距离明显不够。他们用绳子把一个箱子弹射出去，它飞出了门外。他们把另一个箱子向卡车轮胎弹射，箱子弹射后反弹并撞倒了一名摄像师。嘿。太惊人了。这是剧本写好的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，他似乎记得无论他们做什么，他们都无法
I clocked it at 16 minutes 43 seconds. Looks like it takes out the camera guy. Well Ali G from Topeka, Kansas would like to know if this was scripted or just an actual accident. Well, Ali, I was very curious as well. I went to the shooting draft. Here's what it said. We roll, Jim and Dwight place a box of paper on a garbage can lid and slide it on a finished
我计时是16分43秒。看起来好像把摄影师撞倒了。来自堪萨斯州托皮卡的阿里·G想知道这是剧本安排的还是纯粹的意外事故。嗯，阿里，我也非常好奇。我看了拍摄剧本。上面是这样写的：开拍，吉姆和德怀特把一箱纸放在垃圾桶盖上，然后把它滑到一个做好的
track, which stops well short of the mark. They slingshot a box with a rope and it goes flying out the door. They slingshot another box toward a truck tire, which ricochets off and knocks over a camera man. Hey. Amazing. It was scripted. Well Steve Burgess said that he seems to remember that no matter what we did, they could not
轨道上，结果在到达标记前停下了。他们用绳子弹射一个纸箱，纸箱飞出了门外。他们又朝着卡车轮胎弹射了另一个纸箱，纸箱反弹并撞倒了一个摄影师。嘿。太神奇了。这是剧本写的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，他记得无论我们怎么做，他们都无法
get the boxes to really slide very well. He said it was really, really hard. They did use like a kind of silicon grease on the ground, but like there was the friction was too much. The boxes would not slide. They had to cheat this so much. You know, if you really watch carefully, whenever they try to slide them, they don't go very far.
让盒子滑得非常顺畅。他说这真的、真的很难。他们在地上用了一种硅脂，但摩擦力太大了。盒子根本滑不动。他们不得不用各种诡计。你知道，如果你仔细看，每当他们试图滑动盒子时，它们都走不了多远。
I know. I know. Clearly in the script, they imagine that these boxes could just go like flying all the way out the door. Yeah. No. They were never going to travel that far. Jim and Dwight are going to have a joint talking head where they say they have to move
我知道。我知道。显然在剧本里，他们想象这些盒子可以一路飞出大门。是的。不。它们根本不可能滑那么远。吉姆和德怀特将有一个联合单人访谈，他们在访谈中说他们必须搬走
these boxes. So sadly, this has become the best idea. I mean, clearly they can't believe they're following Kevin's idea, but while they're talking about this, Kevin slips on grease behind them and falls down really hard. Yeah, Steve Burgess said that the stunt coordinators put a big old mattress back there and that Brian really did do that fall himself. Good job, Brian. It looks so painful, but he fell on a soft cushy mattress.
这些盒子。所以可悲的是，这成了最好的主意。我的意思是，显然他们不敢相信自己竟然在听从凯文的主意，但正当他们讨论这个时，凯文在他们身后的润滑脂上滑倒了，摔得非常重。是的，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说特技协调员在那里放了一个很大的旧床垫，布莱恩确实是自己摔的。干得好，布莱恩。看起来太痛苦了，但他摔在了一个柔软舒适的床垫上。
Well, now we're going to find out some new information about Daryl, which is he has decided he would like to be fired. Yeah. Andy's trying to introduce him to the new warehouse crew down there in Hank's corner. What's it called? Hank's corner. Yes. Owned by Dwight.
好了，现在我们要发现关于达里尔的一些新信息，那就是他决定他想被解雇。是的。安迪正试图把他介绍给汉克角落那边的仓库新员工。那叫什么？汉克的角落。是的。由德怀特拥有。
Right. Daryl's like, I don't want to meet these people. In fact, I just want to be fired. And Andy kind of pushes back and I guess like re-inspires Daryl to love his job again. Yeah. Well, Daryl gives him an ultimatum. He says, fire me or make me the manager. I earned it.
对。达里尔说，我不想见这些人。事实上，我只想被解雇。安迪有点反推了一下，我想他是重新激起了达里尔对工作的热爱。是的。好吧，达里尔给了他一个最后通牒。他说，要么解雇我，要么让我当经理。这是我应得的。
And Andy pushes back and says, no, this is my job. I earned it. You had a chance for it. And there are a few things they noted. I looked in your file. You hired your friend to replace you who wasn't qualified. They clocked that. He goes on to list a few things.
而安迪反驳说，不，这是我的工作。这是我应得的。你曾有机会得到它。他们注意到了一些事情。我查了你的档案。你雇了你的朋友来代替你，但他并不合格。他们注意到了这一点。他接着列举了几项。
And then he says, and what happened to, you know, business school at night? And he says, well, D'Angelo died and he goes, he didn't die. His brain died. And he said, but I'm manager now. I would approve you to go to night school, but you haven't asked. So you know, what do you want here? Do you want a job? Do you want to improve at this company?
然后他说，还有，你知道的，晚上去商学院是怎么回事？他说，噢，迪安吉洛死了，安迪说，他没死。是他的大脑死了。然后他说，但我现在是经理了。我会批准你去上夜校，但你没问过。所以你知道，你在这里到底想要什么？你想要一份工作吗？你想在这家公司有所提升吗？
What do you want? And Andy actually inspires someone finally. Well, listen, can I get out my bullsh** card for a second? Can I play my bullsh** card? Yeah. I call bullsh** on this. Andy, I could give you the same speech you're giving Daryl. You are no more qualified for this job than Daryl is.
你想要什么？安迪终于鼓舞了某个人。好吧，听着，我可以拿我的废话卡出来一会儿吗？我可以打我的废话卡吗？可以。我指责安迪这是在说废话。安迪，我可以对你发表你对达里尔说的同样的演讲。你对这份工作的资格并不比达里尔高。
You are a hot mess. I mean, you are just the epitome of failing upwards, frankly. And so I guess they're just two people who felt entitled to this job and one of them got it. And the truth is that neither of them were maybe the best fit for the job. But I call bullsh** on Andy claiming that he was like the superior candidate. I call bullsh**. I accept your bullsh** card.
你就是一个烂摊子。我的意思是，坦率地说，你简直就是一路向上失败的缩影。所以我想他们只是两个觉得自己有资格得到这份工作的人，而其中一个人得到了。事实是，他们两个可能都不太适合这份工作。但我认为安迪声称自己是更优秀的候选人纯属放屁。我说是废话。我接受你的废话卡。
I can get as well played. Thank you. Next up, we have a ball tracker. Please, what is it? Daryl has a talking head where he says, you know what? My future won't be determined by seven little white balls. It will be determined by two big black balls because I control my destiny. You're right.
我也可以说配合得很好。谢谢。接下来，我们有一个球体追踪器。请问，这是什么？达里尔有一个单人访谈，他说，你知道吗？我的未来不会由七个小白球决定。它将由两个大黑球决定，因为我掌控着自己的命运。你说得对。
Ball tracker. Ball tracker. Daryl and Andy are going to walk to the warehouse and they're going to see this greased pathway. Erin is going to get loaded on some sort of a, what is it, a slippery disc holding a box of paper and she has a helmet on and they're going to slingshot Erin. Yeah. Why Erin? Why does Erin need to be on it?
球体追踪器。球体追踪器。达里尔和安迪将走到仓库，他们会看到这条涂满油脂的通道。艾琳将被装在某种，是什么来着，一个滑溜溜的圆盘上，手里拿着一箱纸，她戴着头盔，他们要把艾琳像弹弓一样发射出去。是的。为什么是艾琳？为什么艾琳非得坐在上面？
Well, you know, when they were doing it just paper, it was flying everywhere. So maybe they felt like they needed a driver. They wanted to steer the paper down the path. Well, I texted Ellie about this. I wanted to know, what was it like to slide on the grease? Was it crazy? Did you fall over? How was it?
好吧，你知道，当他们只用纸的时候，纸到处飞。所以也许他们觉得需要一个司机。他们想引导纸沿着路径滑过去。好吧，我为此给埃莉发了短信。我想知道，在润滑脂上滑行是什么感觉？太疯狂了吗？你摔倒了吗？感觉怎么样？
And she texted back, Jenna, is there something wrong with me? I have no memory of doing that scene. What? She's like, I don't remember a thing about it. She's like, I don't even know basically what you're talking about. Oh my gosh. She's completely blocked it out. Well, I asked Steve Burgess and he said there's a good reason for that.
她回短信说，珍娜，我有什么毛病吗？我完全不记得拍过那个场景了。什么？她说她对那件事一点记忆也没有。她说她甚至基本上不知道你在说什么。天哪。她完全把它屏蔽掉了。好吧，我问了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，他说这有一个很好的理由。
It's because it wasn't her. It's a stunt person wearing that helmet. Oh, anyone who she doesn't. Yeah. It's a really good double for her. So she never had to do it. Please tell me you texted her back so she doesn't think she's losing it. I did.
那是因为那不是她。戴着那个头盔的是个特技替身。哦，无论她是谁。是的。她是她非常棒的替身。所以她根本不用亲自做。请告诉我你回了她的短信，免得她觉得自己疯了。我回了。
I texted her back and I told her that and she said, oh, thank goodness. I was really concerned. I was worried. Yeah. You'd think you'd remember something like that. Yeah. This episode is going to end with a series of talking heads where everyone says what they would do if they won the lottery.
我回了短信把这告诉了她，她说，哦，谢天谢地。我真的很担心。我当时很焦虑。是的。你本以为你会对这样的事情有记忆。是的。这一集将以一系列的单人访谈结束，每个人都在里面说如果他们中彩票会做什么。
My favorite was Toby's talking head because he said he would spend his free time making his true crime podcast, The Flindersen Viles. Mm-hmm. I would listen to that. You would? Yes. To go to sleep. So crazy.
我最喜欢的是托比的单人访谈，因为他说他会把空闲时间花在制作他的真实犯罪播客《弗林德森·维尔斯》上。嗯。我会听那个。你会吗？会。当作催眠曲听。太疯狂了。
Because I just imagined Toby's cadence. Oh, that would put you to sleep. You're right. Right? I get it now. Yes. The long pauses where he breaks down what happened. Yeah.
因为我只是想象着托比的说话节奏。哦，那会让你睡着的。你说得对。对吧？我现在明白了。是的。他详细分解发生的事情时那种长时间的停顿。是的。
The episode ends with a Pam and Jim talking head. They have come to an agreement on their fantasy of what their life will be after they win the lottery and I need to point out my hair in this talking head. Oh. I think I remember this. If you look at it, it looks like I have those kind of curls, kind of like Nelly Olson from Little House on the Prairie. They're like big barrel curls.
这一集以帕姆和吉姆的单人访谈结束。他们就中彩票后生活的幻想达成了一致，我需要指出这个单人访谈里我的头发。哦。我想我记得这个。如果你看一下，它看起来我好像弄了那种卷发，有点像《草原小屋》里的内莉·奥尔森。它们就像巨大的桶状卷发。
Yeah. Yeah. Around my head. Yeah. I am pretty sure what we would do in the mornings for my hair is we would curl it like that, but then we would leave it. To let it set. Yes.
对。对。缠绕在我的头周围。对。我非常确信我们在早上对我的头发做的是，我们会把它卷成那样，然后就不管它了。
And we would go on and we would rehearse and then right before we got ready to shoot, then Kim Ferry, she would kind of like lightly kind of brush out the curl with her fingertips or something. It would be like her or Debbie would do it. I think we forgot. And we shot this talking head and we had not brushed out the curls. And I have a memory of this happening once on the show and I think this was it. And afterwards we said something.
让它定型。是的。然后我们会继续排练，就在我们准备拍摄之前，金·费瑞会用指尖轻轻地把卷发梳开什么的。就像她或黛比会做的那样。我想我们忘记了。我们拍了这个单人访谈，而我们没有把卷发梳开。我对这件事在剧里发生过一次有记忆，我想这就是那次。事后我们说了些什么。
We said, oh my gosh, we forgot to brush out the curls and they were like, we don't care. We got it. We don't care. But now here it is. All these years later, I'm watching this talking head and oh, yep, there it is. That's the day. We forgot. We didn't brush out the curls.
我们说，哦天哪，我们忘记把卷发梳开了，而他们说，我们不在乎。我们拍到了。我们不在乎。但现在它就在这里。多年后的今天，我正在看这个单人访谈，哦，是的，它就在那儿。就是那一天。我们忘记了。我们没有把卷发梳开。
Yeah. Check it out. Well, Jim and Pam, I guess their fantasies are finally meeting up though if they're going to have a like a New York type of brownstone, but it's going to be on top of a mountain. But yet it'll also be a short walk to like bookstores. It's a short subway stop at the top of the mountain from the best museums. Some can fish from Pam's pottery studio window, you know, but the schools are terrible. Not good schools.
是的。看一看。好吧，吉姆和帕姆，我猜他们的幻想最终还是契合了，如果他们要拥有那种纽约风格的褐石建筑的话，但它将建在山顶上。然而它也将离书店很近。从山顶乘坐短途地铁就能到达最好的博物馆。有人可以从帕姆的陶艺工作室窗户钓鱼，你知道的，但那里的学校糟糕透顶。学校不好。
But what are you going to do? What are you going to do? Yeah. Well, you know, maybe in their fantasy life, they've got to really force it to find common ground. Here you are again. Here you are again. Therapist Angela.
但你又能怎么办呢？你又能怎么办呢？好吧，你知道，也许在他们的幻想生活中，他们必须极力去寻找共同点。你又来了。你又来了。心理医生安吉拉。
Well, guys, that was Lotto, a big thank you to Steve Burgess for all of his awesome behind the scenes info and also to Charlie Grandy and Ellie Kemper and to Mark for helping us kick off this episode and talking to us about playing Nate. How much fun. We had such a great time today. We hope you enjoyed listening and we will see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
好吧，伙计们，这就是《彩票》，非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供的所有精彩幕后信息，也要感谢查理·格兰迪、埃莉·肯珀以及马克帮助我们开启这一集并跟我们聊聊扮演内特的事。多有趣啊。我们今天玩得太开心了。希望你们喜欢收听，我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubba Co. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴·科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。